[Music]
thank you
should we kick this party off what do
you think ready
all right so I thought we would start
first of all Cheers Cheers nice to Matt
yes Matt Mullen Mike thank you for the
Scotch blend
which we shall enjoy here so I'll take a
sip first
we have
Scotch we have go go gadget black tea
what is this called again go Goa go go
go yeah go go guys oh goodness let's go
to India you know the region yes yeah
so this is otherwise known I do have a
backup of Diet Coke in case this is
podcaster speedball so I expect this is
going to be a fantastic episode and for
those who are not watching or those who
may not have video in front of them we
have two different sized scotch glasses
and if you were to walk into Derek's
kitchen
you would find a wide assortment of
glasses namely one other glasses which
is yet larger it's like a Russian
nesting doll of three separate glasses
and those are the only glasses you have
in the house yeah and I didn't buy any
of them they were just so please explain
more oh God because you walk the talk of
certain types of minimalism there are
those out there who may not believe some
of it I'm just saying or maybe skeptical
have a healthy skepticism I'm telling
you guys he's got three glasses in his
pitch and this is my only pair of pants
and yeah so these three glasses I don't
even think about it because I I just
think about having what's enough yeah
right so there's only me and my kid here
and so you come over and you say okay
let's make some scotchy and you're like
do you have any I was like no that
that's all I got I just have these
glasses and honestly I don't even know
where they came from
but they work they work and this is
enough and these little bamboo cups I
got for my kids so that he wouldn't
break them so I have a feeling we will
come back to this in a sense because as
a foreshadowing for people who are
listening
if you have not read the Paradox of
choice Barry Schwartz he talks about
maximizers and satisfices so I think
we'll probably come back to this in a
bunch of different ways but suffice to
say the embodiment of minimalism you
also have
to two very nice suits that act as your
sort of outside in the world attire yeah
which makes sense to me and only two
it's again it's this idea of enough it's
like I wear junk basically home pajamas
I think I'm in those pajamas the the big
baggy t-shirt that somebody handed you
to conference and you would never wear
that outside the house but yeah Michael
Brown with an e in London when I lived
in London right before covet hit I
thought you know I'm living here by Sal
Row in London I'm about to leave England
forever I'm gonna get a custom-made suit
so I looked at um
what was his name
sartorial talks it's an interesting
YouTube channel about somebody diving
deep into like the the craft of fine
tailoring yeah tailoring so he
recommended this guy Michael Brown in
London so yeah I went to Michael Brown
and he said what would you like I said
you're the expert you know just dress me
so he told me what to wear and I do
and because I have a little bit more
context here and then he would ask so
what type of shoes you're gonna wear and
you're like what's your that wear yeah
well how are you thinking about X and
you'd be like how should I be thinking
about it yeah and this is something I
thought
more and more about which is
not so much quantity versus
quality because there's a whole Spectrum
right you can have things that are very
good
and you have
half a dozen of them I'm making this up
of course you can have one thing that is
the best
subjectively or objectively and that's
it you have one or you could have a ton
of things and you're like hey I don't
care about this thing so these are some
this is a disposable item or service or
fill in the blank in my mind I think
we'll we'll probably talk more about
this but
what comes to mind for me also when I
think about say your suits they're great
suits you're happy with them you look
good in them
and I think about in contrast my
my accumulation of ill-fitting suits in
part because my body weight is
fluctuated so much in my life right I've
gone from 145 to 220. in both cases
being pretty lean so I have like kind of
Fatboy Tim jacket and then I've got like
really really skinny emaciated Tim
jacket and then I've got things in
between but I don't need most of those
and yet I still have them right or not
from the perspective of fit but Kevin
Kelly
in his new book which is I think it's
simply called excellent life advice
something like that and one of the bits
of advice was along the lines of yeah
you know how you have that bad pen he's
like throw out the bad pen it's so
liberating don't have the bad pen it's
about self-respect isn't it yeah even
something as simple as a pen when I've
done that I went
I'm better than this
this pen is not going to rule over me
any longer you're only as good as the
worst pen in your house
so let's let's start with the story and
I have not heard this story because you
began telling me and I said no I don't
hear it I said let's save it scuba
diving that'll be my scuba diving scuba
diving that'll be my cue and what it
taught me about empathy and identity
amazing I'll listen to the Ted Talk oh
God all right
so I was in Iceland and I never had any
intention to go scuba diving but I was
at that place in singular Park if you've
ever been there where the two
continental plates meet the American
continental plate meets the Eurasian
continental plate and there's this deep
fissure in the ground but it's Crystal
Clear water so you can see all the way
down I was like oh I want to go in there
it just looks like avian Spring Water
you know poured over rocks with nothing
clouding the water right so I was in
Iceland for a month so I went to take
scuba diving lessons and the instructor
was great so it's dive.is and at the
time it was just him in his basement and
it was me and one other guy learning
scuba diving so
we did the practice in the swimming pool
and we did all the theoretical stuff you
learn to scuba yeah okay and so the
swimming pool was great and I love the
fact that it's calm that you don't need
to panic about holding your breath it's
just slow and meditative
but then the first time we went into the
cold ocean and to be clear I had to wear
one of those giant dry suits you like
you're like a space man with four layers
of rubber and you know stuff over the
rubber so it's very claustrophobic and
then I get into the water and it gets
down to about 20 meters and I'm just
like oh God do I hate this I hate I want
to like I need to go I need to I just
want to go back at home I want to be on
the internet I want to be emailing my
friend I want to talk to my friend I
just want to you know no I just I gotta
get out of here so I wrapped on his tank
and I went up to the top you pointed you
pointed to go up yeah and I was just
like I tore off my mask and I was just
like I said I don't wanna I said I'm
just gonna go you guys go ahead I'm
gonna wait on the side there I'll do you
go ahead I'll just wait and he was so
sweet he was so cool he looked at me and
just stopped for a second and he said
hold on a second he said it's a really
nice day today he said look around look
at those mountains there he goes see
it's a nice day today
he said yeah look look at what a look at
what a beautiful area we're in right now
if you were to leave now he said I know
you're flying back in seven days if
you're to leave now you wouldn't be able
to complete the training and you
wouldn't get your certification I know
you don't want that he said just relax
for a second it's all right
so I just relaxed for a second you know
you inflate your BCD so you're just
going into me
and I went
all right yeah what was I scared of
it's going okay I'm ready and so we go
back down and I completed it it was
great it was no problem I love being
underwater it's wonderful
so that was a completion of my training
the next day was my first official dive
so we're there with a dozen other people
that have flown to Iceland from around
the world including this couple from
Germany
that we're bragging about how many Dives
they've done we've done over 100 Dives
and
so they were acting like know-it-alls
but then they're like oh dry suit we've
never done dry suit before and so
they're getting into dry suit again
it's it's tough It's Different it's
different and so I get underwater but
this time I'm elated I'm underwater just
where I wanted to be in that Crystal
Clear fissure there in thingvillier I
was like wow
and at 20 meters down this is for the
Yanks 60 feet or so yeah which is pretty
deep I mean that's yeah that's the Deep
the bottom of where you're supposed to
go as a beginner
and at the bottom I see the German girl
by herself and her part is not there and
I do the dive manners we're taught where
I gave her the okay symbol yeah and she
gave the not okay symbol and I was like
uh wait they might remember and I was
like okay and again she goes not okay
and I see her eyes are looking crazy and
like oh [__] I've been trained for this
oh my God I can do this okay held onto
her BCD held on to mine inflated hers a
bit asked if she needed my mouthpiece
and she said no one helped her get up to
the surface
and she gets up to the surface and she
rips her mask off just like I did she
said I don't like this I don't like no
this is not good I don't I hate this I
feel bad that I want to go and I said I
just imitated the dive instructor
exactly
I said well hold on a second I said look
around I said it's a really nice day I
said isn't this great I said you see
those mountains over there I said just
relax a second I said I'm here with you
it's okay
and so she calmed down and I saw her go
do the same thing I did and calm down
and then her boyfriend showed up where
the hell is the boyfriend I don't know
but he took her away so you're on your
own babe I'm out of here I've
accidentally missed one step in the
storytelling of this that I should have
included is the night in between those
two days I went home that night
thinking what the [__] I think I just
had a panic attack like I'm not one of
those people like I have no respect for
people who have panic attacks because
usually panic attacks to me I think of
like people who are just like oh no like
my cake is late I'm gonna die and they
freak out over shallow little things
yeah and it seems to me like they have
no perspective on life so then I have no
respect for that kind of silly Panic
right but I had just panicked and it was
involuntary it's like that night
I had at this moment it's like wow what
does that mean
that am I a panic attack person now have
I changed categories from a not panic
attack person to a panic attack person
I just kind of fell asleep with no you
know answers to that so then yeah then
the next day had this thing happen with
a German couple and I feel like that
experience taught me two kinds of
empathy that we
categorize people like I just said the
type of person who has a panic attack
and we think of a category of person
that's say like depressed fat
homeless divorced bankrupt and you think
I would never be those things I'm not
that kind of person
but I thought wow like a lot of these
things are involuntary it's not like
somebody chooses
to be depressed
um
and I realized I had been unfairly
categorizing people the same way I had
unfairly categorized panic attack people
because now I am one right I've had that
addiction right like somebody who said
they would never be an addict then they
find themselves addicted to something
that seemed harmless at first and they
have to admit oh my god I'm an addict
but then I realized that
someday these categories might be me or
anybody else if you're you know
categorizing people this might be you
but then the thing that happened on the
second day where there's another
category that we don't think we could be
which is like hero rescuer hmm
leader athlete things with a positive
connotation millionaire some people in
the past few years have become
millionaires which is something that
they held in a different category and
thought I'd never be that and suddenly
they're you have to admit you know I'm a
multi-millionaire now yeah it's a
category so
I realized that we can even those
categories can be involuntary that you
can suddenly be a rescuer even if you
never intended to be one just through
the power of imitation so yeah you can
deliberately step into these roles by
imitating others
so how do you now think about
labels that you apply to yourself and I
ask that in part because
as you're speaking
I think of how
it can not only be unfair to say I'm
this and not that or that person is this
and not that but if you're applying it
to yourself and you have very narrow
categories
so you have very finely tuned labels I
think it makes you fragile because you
are susceptible to the
the whim of chance in a way that I think
is
not particularly resilient right if
suddenly your circumstances change and
you find yourself in a different
category it can be really upsetting and
how do you think about
what you call or don't call yourself
we're talking a little bit about this at
lunch before we record it right there
people are like I have read stoicism and
now I am a stoic and right there's this
identity that's assumed and these labels
that are applied
and as much as I love stosism even
though I you know invoke that name
I do think that you have to be careful
with labels so how do you think about
that for yourself
well timed for a sip of scotch
sit down
by the way audience the hardest thing
about hitting record on this is that Tim
and I have these like crazy all over the
place conversations in the forest and
whatnot
that it's hard to to remember that we
need to close tangents today yes usually
we open a tangent and I'll close it two
days later yep that's to close tangents
today okay so do you want me to go on my
anti-ism tangent
let's see
is there some unfinished business that
we need to tidy up first well there's a
tiny idea around the identity which is
to just admit that whatever
you are is now and whatever your
preference is now so like when my kid
says I hate Tomatoes I say today and he
goes oh right I hate Tomatoes today
because it's leaving open the
possibilities you might change your mind
tomorrow yeah and he did I hate olives I
hate hate hate olives so badly you yeah
okay and he picked this up from me right
so he's like I hate olives too but he
was just imitating me and then we went
to Subway one day I was so proud of him
he walked up to the counter and he said
I would like olives and they said do you
want anything else he said ham just ham
and olives and they loaded this sandwich
full of olives and I looked at it like
horrified he ate it and loved it he goes
I like olives now it's like yes I love
that switching between identities and so
I used to call myself an entrepreneur
and other people would call me an
entrepreneur and then I did my first
book that was about that
so I got categorized as an entrepreneur
by the way thank you thank you for the
food anything you want yeah yeah I
recommend I recommend people check it
out I've read it multiple times it's
great about you I love that you did the
forward yeah thank you yeah yeah you're
welcome but
for years I kept calling myself an
entrepreneur until one day I realized
like wait a second this is expired like
somebody who is an athlete in high
school can't keep calling himself an
athlete forever yeah I've learned that
one you have to keep earning that title
or it expires right same thing with
being a good friend yeah
same thing with any labels that we call
ourselves you can't just keep using that
forever yeah you have to keep it up
where it expires so if you realize that
your previous identity is expiring you
have the choice then of either admitting
like I was an entrepreneur I was a
musician
or
if you don't want it to expire well then
you need to do something about it and
that could actively be a good friend not
just keep calling yourself a good friend
or go actively be an entrepreneur if you
want to keep calling yourself that so
maybe skipping ahead because I do like
mixing tangents great but that's the
nature of conversation especially when
you have go go gadget T and Scotch
involved so
we were talking about this the other
night dinner we use language we're
creatures of language I mean part of the
reason that we become such a dominant
pest on the planet is our ability to use
Concepts and abstraction right
and you'd mentioned at one point
thinking of yourself
after entrepreneur as a writer
how did you make that switch
looking to Your Heroes
I call it my people compass
that like if you're not sure which way
to go
you can ask yourself well who do I
admire who do I like so for me this was
like as I was not sure what direction I
wanted to go like I I am an entrepreneur
and I'm a programmer and I'm an author I
actually thought about it in
order maybe programmer first
entrepreneur and then writing seemed to
be something I was doing is just like a
waste product
a metabolite of your other Focus it's
like it was like it was like and as I'm
doing my thing if I learn some lessons
there I just put them into writing yeah
but then I noticed that all of my heroes
were authors these were the people I
looked up to the most
and that helped me realize my values
like it helped reveal my values so
ultimately like we wanted to be our
ideal selves
and I think that
Your Heroes
are your idealized self right it's kind
of that's why we idolize certain people
as we want to be like them so that kind
of reveals what your values are so in
that moment I went oh my God
that's right
in my heart I'm actually more of an
author and programming is fun I love
programming I love what it empowers and
I think we're going to talk about that
later and I'm not an entrepreneur
anymore so in that moment I was like
that's it I'm really an author now
aren't I wow that feels weird to me I
never thought of myself as an author
so the reason I call it a people Compass
is it's related to
when you're not sure what business to
start like a lot of people are you know
they're looking at the many different
options right now the way I think about
it is asking yourself what kind of
people do I like being around
because these are the people you're
going to be serving you have to like
them so you want to love your customers
and love serving them because ultimately
even if it's the money what you really
really want is the emotional fulfillment
right yeah totally so you might get
lucky by strategically choosing an
industry or a market that's on its way
up and you might get really lucky and
become a billionaire doing something but
what if your customers are jerks right
like would you be happy getting rich
running an all-night vaping store you
know if you think of the kind of
customers that were coming into your all
night vaping store
are these the people you want to serve
and would you be happy even if you made
a million dollars doing that I think
you'd you'd feel pretty mixed about it
you're probably a little embarrassed to
tell you about my new startup
right vaping anyway so asking yourself
like what kind of people do you want to
be around decentralized blockchain baby
seal clubbing
Expeditions
not sure I want to hang out with the
people who might go from that tour run
by AI
yeah I think that if you set up your
business
to serve the people that you love being
around yeah even if it makes less money
you're going to be much happier yeah so
that's where I'm at right now like right
now I'm not an entrepreneur but I'm
starting to get that itch I'm starting
to feel like doing something and if I do
it'll just be to be around the people
that I already
love okay so let's poke at that a little
bit
being around the people you love there
are many ways to do that
why do you think you are maybe leaning
towards the entrepreneur vehicle for
doing that versus doing other things is
it what you know is there more to it
because it's it's asking yourself what
would you do even if it didn't pay yeah
right so
I'll just pick one example and don't
hold me to this world if I don't end up
doing this idea
do you know that's like seven years ago
I happen to mention that that week we
talked I was enjoying learning the
history of hip-hop and for six years
people keep telling me like so history I
was like it was just it was that week
come on so all right right now now I
like olives stop lecturing me I might
pass yourself so right now an idea I'm
having is
100 Year hosting Legacy personal
websites so that setting up a trust so
that your personal website will last on
for 100 years or 50 years after you die
yeah sure and this is the kind of thing
I care about so deeply that I would do
it even if it didn't pay I would do it
as volunteer work and I really like
people that have personal websites
they're my kind of people that that
enjoy technology for its own sake that
took
a little
umko power
what do you call that go power no no
where somebody takes initiative somebody
took the initiative is that English go
ahead I don't speak Esperanto yet oh
yeah somebody took a little and set up
their own website I like these people
yeah I like people that have personal
websites that aren't doing it for money
yeah they're my kind of people and so I
would be proud to serve them so that's
all I meant by that
okay so so many directions we can go
here I think
you alluded to it so why not hop to it
programming the empowerment that can
provide
let's talk about escaping the cloud all
right or broadly speaking Tech
Independence yeah and to set the stage
for folks we were walking down the
street here in Wellington beautiful
Wellington new hopefully Central London
well yeah the central area is a little
bit like hit Ashbury in some respects
but for the people who get the reference
but all in all beautiful city and with
lots of hiking trails shockingly similar
to Northern California even I felt like
I was flying into SFO you have Monterey
Pine here you have a eucalyptus which we
both borrowed from Australia you have
nasturtiums a lot of the vegetation here
is similar it's really
nostalgic and kind of eerie in a way to
be here because I feel like I'm back in
Northern California it's like being in a
time machine in any case we were walking
around not in the on the nature side of
things but downtown and I said you know
I'd love to ask you about cyber security
and I said let's say and I'm not going
to use anyone's name but somebody who's
very technical and Hyper paranoid I was
like let's say they're a 10. let's say
your mom is a one not to make
assumptions about your mom but I will
where do you fall on the cyber security
spectrum and that opened up a
I think fun discussion we chatted you
also then wrote in your diary about it
the next morning yeah because I'm slow
like that you'll ask me something like
that and in the moment so we're walking
down Courtney place I'll give some
half-ass answer and then later that
night I'm like oh I got a better knee
and I'll push back a little bit be a
slow is relative I mean I think that you
were very coherent and you thought about
it before you launched off into some
type of of monologue which you didn't it
was a conversation but you then refined
it the next morning yeah so let's talk
about this because you gave a couple of
I wouldn't say recommendations you you
described a few things you do personally
that I found very interesting one of
which was you don't use the cloud yeah
which I think will get a lot of people's
attention because in part I think there
are many people who feel myself included
that there's something uncomfortable
about it
but
I assume since I'm non-technical there
really just is not an alternative
right but there is part of me that's
very privacy sensitive and is
fundamentally uncomfortable with having
all this stuff all this miscellanea all
these impulsive ridiculous group chats
and whatever
backed up somewhere else
for a lot of reasons your phone book
your calendar yeah all of that there's
something deeply uncomfortable about it
and yet I use the off the shelf tools
because everyone else does and I just
assume there are no Alternatives that
are feasible for a muggle like myself
poor Tim poor Tim you're incapable
I took notes because
although I love Tim's podcast I love it
most when people come and give us like
an intense data dump yeah I know this so
all right guys I prepared a couple hours
and here you go so I'm going to
unapologetically read from my notes to
give you the best bang for buck of your
time listening so Tech Independence is
all about
the fact that I think the main sales
pitch of the cloud is now don't worry
your little head about that let us take
care of it we'll keep all of your data
see isn't that easier now there we've
got your data yeah and it actually
reminded me of something I think you
said in for our body about yoga studios
that no it's not the best thing for your
health but it's it's a better profitable
pitch for them to sell you a yoga studio
instead of the deadlift yeah free
weights yeah there's a lot of that in
Fitness overall for sure so there's an
incentive this is the tech equivalent of
that that I wish that history had gone
such a way that we all had our own
little private server at home but
instead the cloud might have made a
better sales pitch saying no no give us
all your stuff we'll take care of it
forever so
my idea is if you spend a few hours to
learn how to do it yourself you'll just
have Tech Independence what that means
is self-reliance it gives you better
security better privacy better Freedom
better flexibility and total control and
I think it's a great use of your time to
spend a few hours learning to do this
kind of like somebody learning to drive
manual transmission right you don't need
to do it but this is a good life skill
to have especially imagine if we're in a
world that had more you know just 50
years ago or now in a lot of countries
so have you heard I don't know if you've
heard the same stories I have about how
many people have lost their Google
accounts
there was a guy I know who's a very
Savvy Tech entrepreneur in Singapore who
because he was so tech savvy he put all
of his kids photos in the cloud since
the day his kid was born he put
everything onto Google photos for 10
years his kid was 10 years old the day
that he started a new company and said
I'm going to do the Google Apps for
business and it asked him a quick
question would you like to merge this
would your existing Gmail account he
said yes he merged it and the next day
his wife was like honey where are all
the photos of our kids they're in Google
photos she said no they're not and he
looked up he's like oh my God you mean
they're gone and he emailed customer
service and they said well no you chose
to merge your accounts and we warned you
that they only said well could you
please recover them they said no they're
gone this poor guy has no photos of his
kid from age zero to ten because he
trusted the clown I mean sorry Cloud
careful says clowns
the clowns and the clowns get the clown
text snark okay so
do you do that on purpose I did oh it
was good yeah anytime when somebody
talks about the cloud you can change it
to an end
keep keep all my contacts in the clown
so everything I'm going to describe here
takes just a few hours to set up this
isn't a major major thing it's not that
hard listeners
of yours are used to being suggested to
learn how to do something and let me
also preface this first quick second
this is not a tangent by saying
I do not experience you maybe I'm
missing something maybe you have spider
holes dug in the backyard I do not
experience you to be a hyper paranoid
person at all so I just want to mention
that because folks might think oh my God
this guy's got like 20 years worth of
oatmeal and like you know gold bars and
guns in the basement and he's this guy
maybe right I want to sort of set the
proper reference point which is I don't
experience you to be a paranoid person
not at all so first let me just say the
first thing you need is to get your own
server which
is as simple as five dollars a month if
you go to there's a company I recommend
called vulture.com but it's spelled v
u l t r.com good to use some branding
help but yeah so they have something
called Cloud compute for five dollars a
month
where basically that's setting up a
private slice it's just yours but on a
shared computer this is like a virtual
private server virtual private server
exactly I was trying to knock it
technically yeah um so and a server for
people who don't know I know this is
going to be old news for a lot of folks
what is the server sounds super
complicated it's just a computer that's
always online got it that's it okay
publicly accessible always online
doesn't even necessarily need to be
public we'll get to that because I think
for setting up your server there are
three options either the five dollars a
month vulture.com
Cloud compute number two search the web
for cloud compute for cheap dedicated
server so now a dedicated server is an
actual piece of Hardware that is only
yours not shared with anybody else so if
you want more privacy just spend a
little extra money and get a dedicated
server which means yeah this physical
Hardware
you're the only person that has access
they have physical access to it but you
have the only root password and it's
going to be an encrypted hard drive
we'll get to that the third option is go
to any used Marketplace and find an old
used Lenovo ThinkPad ideally from the
T400 series you can get these for under
200 now and they're great and they run
any old operating system and you would
just set this up in your closet and keep
the master version of your server in
your closet and then the other things
would be mirrors of that but we'll get
to that in a second
okay so here comes my you have done some
work here's my quick how-to and I'm
going to tell you a few things here that
aren't complete instructions but they're
enough for you to search the web so I'll
tell you what to do and you can search
the web for exactly how
the first thing you're going to need to
do is to use the terminal so the command
line in the Mac it's built in you go
into utilities folder it's called
terminal on Windows it's called
Powershell and anybody using Linux you
know what it is so the operating system
I'm going to recommend the one I use is
called openbsd and we touched on this on
the street the other night the reason I
use openbsd is reach Sato masochism
Berkeley software distribution I was
born in Berkeley California and kind of
like more people named Dennis go into
Dentistry because there's an affiliation
of names for economics pointed that out
I always wonder if my Affinity with the
BSD operating systems is because I was
born in Berkeley
anyway but the reason I got turned on to
openbsd is because I used to have Linux
server as a public server and it was
hacked one day and the guy at the data
center said uh yeah that's been
happening a lot lately he said you might
want to switch to BSD it's a lot more
secure so opendsd is designed for me the
ground up by super security Freaks and
part of why it's so secure is it's so
simple it's a very very simple operating
system that doesn't do everything under
the sun it does this that I'm describing
and it does it really well and it's
secure as hell and it's got as I
understand it few lines of code yes
right which means let's just say you're
a writer the more you write the higher
the frequency of typos yes don't want
bugs yes in your code that can be
exploited the less code the better so
install openvsd and follow the
instructions to encrypt one of the disk
partitions in there as you're installing
it then you're going to use SSH which
stands for secure shell to log into it
then on your home computer use that
terminal to generate a private SSH key
you do SSH Keygen the type you want is
Ed 25519
and then that's going to generate two
keys a private key and a public key you
upload the public key to your server and
then after you do that
edit your SSH configuration file to
disable password logins so now the only
way to log into your server is with your
private public key that you just
generated right very similar to the
crypto public private thing
then you go into your pf.com settings
you edit your firewall to only allow
Port 22 which is the port that SSH uses
to connect once you've done that voila
like now your server is super secure
nobody can get in except you from your
computer to the generated private key
through SSH is the only way to connect
to that server can you explain the
generated private key yeah it's really
just a single command you type on the
terminal if you type SSH Keygen space
Dash t space ed25519
it will ask you for an optional password
and it just creates the private key and
the public key same name but one has the
dot pub at the end and then you just use
whatever tool you want to upload the dot
Pub to your remote server you put it in
the correct place an authorized Keys
file and voila now
it will instead of asking you for your
password it just uses the private key
and the public key matching to let you
in got it so it's like Marco Polo okay
yeah Warren as opposed to entering a
password every time right and that's why
then you want to change the SSH server
configuration files to disable passwords
so even if a billion script kitties were
trying to hack your server to guess your
password passwords are just disabled
okay this is keep track where you are
yeah do you think this will become and
I'm non-technical folks you've probably
guessed but this type of Marco Polo I'm
not gonna remember the proper way the
private keys and so on private public
keys or whatever the term is will become
more and more prevalent as say Quantum
Computing and so on allows
the current level of encryption to be
decrypted more and more effectively I'm
just wondering about well this is going
to take us off on a major change what
our phones are already doing behind the
scenes with WhatsApp encrypted chats or
FaceTime or even just our phones
themselves when you type in that code
when you first turn on your phone
I think our phones are already behind
the scenes using public private key yeah
so that's the way it should be it's just
it is the best solution so far I think
yeah side note if you have four digit
password on your phone you can change
that to eight digit simple simple
upgrade yep in settings okay so next
thing you need a domain name my
recommended place to get a domain name
is a wonderfully nerdy non-commercial
site called bookmyname.com
you don't get 10 Affiliates absolutely
not wait till you see the site it's like
a wonderful old school nerdy there's no
affiliate program there as a backup I
use netim.com both of these are French
companies okay and there's a third one
in Portland Oregon that I like called
porkbun.com yeah all three of these are
really good reputable places to get a
domain name I recommend them no
affiliate fees at all I just like them I
use them okay so now you've got a server
and
the best thing to start with like you
said I'm not a guy that's got stockpiles
of oatmeal and gold but once you've got
I don't know why you picked oatmeal
once you've got your own server it puts
everything else into perspective so
that's really where I'm coming from when
I say like I don't do things in the
cloud it's because
when companies come out and say we can
take care of this for you yeah it's like
you've already got in your your bread
and peanut butter and jam in the kitchen
and somebody says we can make a sandwich
for you in your own home you think I
don't need your help so for those who
heard this Scotch really just happened
because Lord that was not very much but
you'll have extra personality for this
episode folks so for those people who
listen to what you just said they're
like I think I just heard a lot of
Klingon I'm not sure but I can't parse
what any of that means it sounds
overwhelming right what would you say to
them
I care about this so much that I'm gonna
set up
a really dead simple thing that's
basically just do this copy paste this
this is going to work look at that so
email me God damn it email you write a
blog post Derek everyone else
blog post what's that yeah you've only
written 500 million blog posts since
like 1987. but until until I write up
kind of I actually you know what I
registered the domain name Cloud free
with the dot ee for for Estonia yeah
so like cloudfree.com wasn't available I
don't know I just thought it was clever
okay
No but somebody I'm going to write this
up into a
a very simple
you don't need to understand this yet
just do this eventually you understand
because that's how I learned my photos
of Derek's Services all my photos right
right that's what I really wanted I want
your photos because that's how we all
learned it first right it's often like
just do this you'll understand it later
yeah you cannot just do it and I think
that's a fine way to learn if you trust
the source right trust me
so it's not as hard as it sounds okay
gotta try it out it's like something
describing how to hit a baseball you'd
be like what the [__] that was like 15
pages of describing and that sounds too
hard it's like actually now I just gotta
try it a few times by the way you know
what's cute my kid didn't know what
baseball is they played baseball last
week at school and he said Dad what's
this thing with the squares and set up
in a
and he he hit a home run on his first
try oh wow from there yeah exactly
everybody's cheering for me but I didn't
know what I was supposed to do they told
me to run okay so now let's talk about
some applications okay so you have a
server set up here's what you're gonna
do with it first do your contacts and
calendar so I don't like the fact that
my phone automatically gives Google all
of the contacts and all of my calendars
or apple or whatever
so you can set up it's called radical
r-a-d-i-c-a-l-e the website is
radical.org it's absolutely free open
source i c a l e yes okay dot o r g it's
absolutely free open source it sets up
what's known as a card DAV or and a
caldav server on your server so this
will just this will be the new server
that you sync your contacts and
calendars to so it's dead simple blew my
mind you install a radical on your
server you just basically type one
command and it says okay it's running
you say okay and then you go into your
phone and instead of telling Apple to
manage your calendar and contacts you
just set it to your domain name but and
suddenly it says okay synchronized and
now every new contact you add and every
calendar entry is synchronized with your
server not apple and actually I have
gone through this process before and I
can tell people it's quite simple
because things have probably changed but
quite a few years ago if you wanted your
say
Cal on Mac and Google cal to sync huge
pain in the ass right you had to use a
third so you would have to use a third
party and at least I ended up using
caldev a long time ago that's since
changed but yeah so this is not very
hard that's why I started with this yeah
it's like the simplest thing to set up
and the most sensitive in a way or some
of the most sensitive yeah it's so
important to know that my contacts
aren't being sent to other people and
and then you see it backed up yourself
so that situation because there are some
people that get locked out of their
Gmail account or whatever and then
they're just screwed because all their
contacts are in there but yeah you have
them yourself okay so next thing is file
storage where photos books ebooks movies
documents everything else they're just
files so the first thing you want to do
is to export them out of the apps that
are like the world Garden apps like
Kindle and Apple's photos app and save
it as regular files ePub jpeg mp3 mp4
just Open Standards so you export it out
you save it there and now you've just
got regular file files you don't need
iCloud you don't need Dropbox you don't
need Google drive you've got your own
server so
every computer has this dead simple
little program built into it called
rsync
r-s-y-n-c well Max have it built in
Windows I think you might need to
install it or maybe it's there with new
Powershell
and all it does is synchronize the
difference so if you have 10 000 files
and you've changed three of them today
and your remote server has 10 000 files
but not the new three you type rsync and
it'll just send the newest three that
you've changed that's it so rsync is
built in but you have to manually type
rsync and the command and your server
name and it'll go so that's what I do
but if you're a fan of Dropbox there's a
free replacement for Dropbox called sync
thing s y n c t h i n g dot net so it's
totally free open source I want to give
you more scotch just see what it does to
your spelling
so it's completely free and open source
and it does that more like automatic
style instead of manual synchronization
well let me pause so in your particular
case do you like automatic sync I like
having the delay between my servers
because if you [__] up yes right because
if I accidentally delete a file even if
it's a week later we'll get to actually
you know what I'll talk about this right
now I have my servers cloned so that's
actually the next step I would recommend
anyway once you've got this and it's
working for extra security go back and
repeat that first step and set up
another server with a different company
in a different country
and do it again to the SSH Port thing
then you can use rsync or sync think not
just to clone between your computer and
your server but that server and the
other server I have a great idea okay
you ready yeah all right so this next
chapter
of of Dr sewers
entrepreneur interacting with customers
you like your own personal websites you
could create a service that helps people
liberate themselves from the cloud
for those who own personal websites I
like it anyway you know just an idea
because you seem to be
philosophically aligned with this yeah
I'm passionate about it it upsets me
when people are bound to the cloud
they're just going to use everything in
the company's hand them or the dependent
on this it's about being dependent it's
about the self-reliance people who are
dependent on others like imagine if
everybody in their own home was like
depend on somebody else to make them
food they didn't know how to make their
own food yeah you'd feel bad for them
like come on it's not that hard here's a
knife here's some bread some peanut
butter see you could do it you know like
that's how I feel with these things you
only need three glasses it's easy
I would also say that it's not just
about being dependent it's about being
informed so having do you have complete
understanding
or near complete understanding of how
you are storing sensitive information
right when's the last time anyone
listening to this or even I'll speak for
myself Yours Truly read the complete
terms and service when something pops up
and it's 27 pages and you're like yeah
yeah Okay click accept there's a lot of
stuff buried in there yeah there's a
reason there are armies of lawyers that
work on terms of service and that
they're updated constantly which is nice
to tune into people who care about that
stuff deeply and they can act as a nice
natural filter to let you know if
somebody's being good or being bad yeah
that's how we found you know when I
recommended bookmyname.com for domains
it was like some super nerd that
recommended that they're like oh these
guys are old school eunuchs you want to
go with these guys like you know they're
not these new salesmen trying to you
know raise venture capital for their
domain selling these are just old school
nerds doing it for the right reason
that's what I like to hear these are my
people okay so I have three servers Now
set up in New Zealand US and Germany and
I like the delay between them so I have
one that I update it like every night
sometimes multiple times a day manually
yeah I just type our sink right before I
shut down my computer backs up my
whatever today's work to my remote
server
and then about once a week I back it up
to the second server then about once a
month I back it up to the third server
and I really like that delay because
there have been times that I've deleted
something like a whole week later went
oh crap let me ask a dumb question maybe
why delete anything storage is so cheap
I know no I mean more like
deleted lines of code like I thought I
was done with that there was a revision
that you want to undo yeah yeah and
sometimes even these can get but
sometimes I'm not and sometimes it's
gone it's rare but every now and then
yeah yeah okay so
website is a no-brainer the open BSD
operating system comes with its own web
server so I highly recommend no offense
to
don't install WordPress
we love you Matt I adore you Matt but I
think everybody should learn how to do
it themselves yeah it's not that hard to
do an H1 tag H2 p-tag
Uli ahref image source you can learn it
in an hour yeah and voila now you can
make your own HTML website
because I get this question about once a
week by email people saying what do you
recommend I want to make my own site
well hold on listen not to push back but
just to stress test a little bit
WordPress is open source why not use it
you could but see WordPress is like I
think last time I counted 38 billion
lines of code yeah
and it does way more than what you need
so it's kind of like if you said
I need some scissors and somebody handed
you to the contents of an entire
hardware store yeah and like no I really
just need to
cut this right so I think most people
what they want from a website is I have
some thoughts
I want to put them in writing for the
world to read or I have a couple photos
that's what most people want but then I
love WordPress and I used it for years
but it does everything and I think it
intimidates people to the point of
paralysis yeah so that's why I say well
no no no hold on my top recommendation
is don't let people tell you that this
is complicated because if you look at
WordPress or similar services and by the
way I'm just saying WordPress I mean it
could be ghost it could be any of these
things you get the impression that
making a website is hard yeah but it's
not it's just a plain text file that you
change it from txt to dot HTML and you
add in a couple bracket tags yeah and
that's it yeah and then you upload it
and it works and the world can see it so
I just constantly remind people how
simple this can be and I say that even
if you just do it this way for the first
month please like make your own static
HTML web page even I think it's a good
exercise even if you end up later using
something exactly right that's what it's
getting to yeah so start by doing it
that way and then
if you need something that another
service offers you'll recognize that you
need it because you'll know I agree with
that I mean I edited the first 30 to 40
episodes in my podcast
um
which is a lot of work yeah and I'm not
a master at it and there are far better
people who work on it now for these
later episodes but I felt good doing it
in the beginning yeah and I was like all
right if I'm going to delegate anything
to the extent that it's feasible I'd
love to learn how to do each thing yep
otherwise how am I going to assess
anything yeah exactly yeah
okay I'll name one last one and then
we're done with this subject the last
thing I'm going to recommend is email so
at very least get off Gmail and use your
own domain name it's so important to
switch your email to your own domain
name
you can do that with G Suite though I
know but we're talking about The
Liberation the independence it's knowing
that you aren't dependent yeah on these
guys so I think it's it's crucial to
extract yourself from the we'll take
care of it for you thing
the three different options in order the
simplest cutest little one I've found is
mailbox.org is in Germany and for one
dollar a month they do nothing but host
your email and I think maybe your
calendars but you know we've already
talked about that yeah but mailbox.org
you point your domain name at them they
do your mail they're cute they're great
they're all privacy focused if you want
the luxury full premium and Suite of
like the best email client on Earth you
go to fastmail.com fastmail.com is
amazing it's five dollars a month
but again it's they're taking care of it
for you so you know the third option is
coming you can host your email yourself
on your own server it's dead easy to
receive email it's a little harder to
send email you'd have to set up a few
config files but it's not that hard I do
it myself it's a bit Advanced but it's
possible and I assume that that would
come maybe as you know step eight after
you've done other things right that's
like if you're starting on the bunny
slopes which were the first stages this
is like okay now you're getting on some
Moguls yeah don't try this day one
okay use
get familiar with the gear first so I
would be curious to know how you would
reply to people who are listening and
they're like
mailbox.org Germany FastMail I've never
[__] heard of these things wait wait
hold on hold on which is not to say
they're not robust and amazing and cute
as you put it but they'll say I have
more confidence in Google being around
in five years than I do in these
companies which I know nothing about
ultimately
you can have certain degree of
Liberation but if your infrastructure
fails or these people put up a
closed for business sign and suddenly
the hardware Pawn which things are being
stored is game over I I guess I'm
wondering how you would address people
with those types of concerns everything
I've recommended here was recommended
with that in mind you should expect that
you will outlive most businesses yeah I
think that to me is the biggest
misconception that people have about
Facebook
or Apple or Google fit it's likely you
might outlive Google and Facebook yeah
you know those of us who are around in
the first.com history repeats yeah it's
not it's certainly well within their own
possibility yeah it was Unthinkable in
whatever 1999 that Myspace wouldn't be
around maybe what was that 2003. so how
is mailbox.org better because everything
is done with your own domain name so if
mailbox.org ever sends actually if they
just disappeared one day you'd go you
just log into your domain name router
and just route it to another service
because everything's being sent to you
know Tim at tim.com or whatever yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you have your own
domain name you can just route it to a
different mail server same thing with
the servers I'm talking about if one of
these services in Germany or New Jersey
suddenly went under no big deal you've
got your clone your remote clone your
remote server is right so all of this is
expecting everybody to fail yeah so the
conclusion is I think this is a great
use of your time it's liberating it's
empowering and then when somebody tries
to sell you a service
you'll know that you can do it yourself
if you want to and you might still
choose to have them do it question for
you so if somebody's listening and they
say
there's no [__] way I'm going to do
all that however I'd be interested in
dipping my toe in the water and maybe
doing the first thing just to learn some
new technology gain some confidence
I'm not going to do the whole kit and
caboodle because it just sounds
overwhelming but like I want to do sort
of a science project
with yeah some experimentation what
might you recommend to them I'd say the
first baby step is to get your own
domain name definitely
and then move your email off of Gmail
and just go to some third-party provider
review okay so you start with email I
think so it's the simplest it's the only
one in there that's not truly setting up
your own server
you know obviously that's the next step
it's just just do that first thing and
just have like a couple hours of
something that feels uncomfortable and
new to you but voila you have a server
that's running anywhere in the world and
once you have a server everything else
is easier so but yeah the baby steps is
to just get your own domain name and
switch your email to that and try to
just move everything off of Gmail or
just let your old gmail be your junk
account okay question for you personally
if you had to choose between having your
email off of the cloud or
calendar and contacts
but you can only choose one so calendar
and contacts come together email is
another which would you choose
I don't know why there's a sense of
happiness in having my calendars and
contacts be on my own server I lean that
way too and I I don't know if I could
verbalize why that's the case mail
sending has been come unfortunately
difficult because a lot of things get
marked as spam unless you do a bunch of
more complicated things that's right I
didn't think about that I can see that
being a huge problem so the way I
actually have my mail server set up
right now
pretends to be Gmail
all incoming email comes directly into
my server yeah but for sending I
actually use a service called mailgun
that just handles the sending so they
take care of all the deliverability yeah
so it's not an ESP but it's helping or
maybe it isn't ESP like an email service
provider oh it is yeah I guess they're
outgoing only yeah I think I wonder I
think send grid does yeah handle some of
this as well yeah they're one of the
same
so you're really just using their sympty
servers just to send the outgoing mail
but receiving it privately so that's my
balance those guys have done such a good
job at least last I checked and I met
them when they were just starting I met
them at Tech stars a million years ago
and this is an example of where being
non-technical hurt me because I just
didn't know what I was looking at the
guys are super great clearly very smart
but I was like I don't understand yeah
this wait can we tell people the Shopify
oh man I mean my most expensive mistake
no no the my little thing with Toby oh
yeah yeah yeah
I'll leave I'll let that one sorry I
didn't mean no that's okay yeah selling
Shopify earlier was my most expensive
mistake ever as their first advisor and
they had like 10 employees so so
audience there was this kid moment
I just want to say that God do I love
the Shopify guys I just thought they're
so great Toby Harley the whole gang just
great humans it's really it makes me so
happy when the good guys and gals do
well right it just makes me so happy so
yeah cute story
which I had never heard which was
shocking yeah sometimes people ask
if I can introduce them to you yeah no
yeah I respect your time yeah I
appreciate that by the way I love your
email address oh yeah yeah yeah
it's essentially [__] off at
timferriss.com yeah it's not that
aggressive but it makes it clear like
think twice before sure don't you dare
give this to anyone yeah yeah at
timferriss.com that is his personal
email yeah yeah a little wordy but you
know it's worth it give him a hurdle oh
Toby so
I love the Ruby programming language and
so before there was Ruby on Rails I
learned Ruby in a cabin in Sweden that I
was offline for two weeks so I brought a
programming book with me I was like well
I'm gonna be offline for two weeks I
might as well learn something new so
there was this really unknown little
programming language called Ruby I was
like that sounds fun so I grabbed this
Ruby book installed Ruby on my laptop
and went off to this cabin in Sweden in
the winter for two weeks I was offline
and I learned Ruby for two weeks I came
back going that was so much fun I wish I
could use this to make websites and
there was news that there was this guy
named David in Denmark who was
doing something with websites and Ruby
so I email them saying hey somebody said
you're making like a web framework and
Ruby and he emailed back saying not
ready yet that's all he said for those
who don't know that's dhh yeah David
hanmeier Hansen yeah and so rails came
out about eight months later and at
first look I was just like huh this is a
little confusing
I don't really get it and so I posted to
like the Ruby mailing list like can
anybody tell me
how this works like it's and I'd be
happy to pay somebody for an hour of
their time to show me how this works so
some guy named Toby said I'll show you
rails for a hundred dollars I'll spend
an hour with you so I paid Toby a
hundred dollars to show me rails for an
hour and he showed me over the phone we
never met face to face it was all just
over the phone I was living in LA and
Toby was great he showed me how rails
works and like got me really into it I
was like all right I'm in and so my old
company CD Baby we started converting
everything over to rails I was like this
is great so a couple years later
I get this email from Toby saying hey
not sure you remember me the guy that
taught you rails he said could you
introduce me to Tim Ferriss because I've
got this little e-commerce thing I'm
doing I was like e-commerce thing
no I was like sorry dude I don't do that
no I don't know so I didn't introduce
you guys and I was double through so I
was thrilled later to find out that
Toby's little e-commerce thing is
Shopify or became Shopify I can't shop
before you know became the Shopify and
then I was thrilled to find out like
another year or two later that you were
we met at railsconf of all places wow I
was a speaker at railsconf which I felt
I was
it all worked out Toby's a spectacular
human big fan it's kind of funny that
somebody listening to this thinks that
we might be talking about tech and
programming the whole time but no that
was it we're done we're not gonna talk
about Unix command line terminal stuff
anymore yeah well Zig and zag so let's
Zig a little bit
you know there's so many options here
for where to go next I think
one I'd actually like to talk about is
the unoptimized life
if you'd be open to going there next
what do you think yeah all right let's
do it London London 2019. this is gonna
be good on the train from Oxford to
London and it was one of those days that
looked like it might rain it might not
so we made a plan on the train I said
okay if it's raining we're going to go
to the museum and if it's not raining
we're going to the zoo and he said okay
so we got to marlabin station in central
London we walked out and he said you
know Dad I don't want to go to the zoo
or the museum I said what do you want to
do he said let's just walk around
you sure yeah okay we just walked around
so at every intersection he said let's
go this way is that okay and so he just
led the way through London that day we
walked around for eight hours so
at one point he was jumping around park
benches and met these kids from Croatia
where they got into a little tickling
match and another time in like a little
Alleyway he saw this huge cardboard box
that was like almost as big as he is and
he got into this cardboard box and wore
it like a turtle shell so he walked
around London in a cardboard box for
like an hour and everybody would do
double takes looking at him and he felt
so cool in the cardboard box and then at
some point we found ourselves right in
front of the West End musical Wicked and
the show was about to begin in 10
minutes and I said do you have any
tickets what are the best tickets you
have they had eight throw Center tickets
they had two left so we're like yeah
let's do it let's go see Wicked so he
left his cardboard box there we went in
and saw Wicked and he at one point he
whispered to me he said Dad
okay and later I look over and he's
holding her hand he held her hands and
so
was over we go home and I tuck him into
bed that night
and I said did you have a good day and
he said I had a great day and I said all
right so what was your favorite thing
today and he thinks for a bit and then
he said
cardboard box
and I was just like I marveled at that I
was just thinking later like
if I would have planned and said no
we're going to the museum come on it's
an important museum for you to know then
he wouldn't have had this
unoptimized experience and stumbled into
the cardboard box and so of course you
know I think about life and I think
about like
that day as a metaphor
for how we tend to make plans because
plans seem to be the the tool we use to
make the most of our time but that
doesn't always make sense does it
because like as you go through life you
keep getting new information moment to
moment
that helps you make the the best
decision for that moment not what you
thought would be the best decision
earlier when you made a plan which was a
prediction
so I think about like for example this
stupid house I'm in right now
so this is my stupid house everybody I
don't like this house
but here I am I would never guess based
on your assortment of matching plate
how much energy I've clearly put into
this house and making it perfect with
all of its Decor
there's nothing on the wall no furniture
yeah except for some mice yeah
legitimately yeah I have three pet mice
we were going to bring them out that'd
be distracting
I thought about getting rid of this
house and getting a house that was more
suited for me
and I actually put an offer on a place
and it was a really nice place it was at
the end of Clyde key Wharf who's out
there like in the water and oh man it
was nice and so it was like the night
before my offer was accepted and it was
the night before I was going to put down
the deposit it was going to be mine
I fell asleep that night thinking
like At first thought I was thinking I'm
gonna be so happy tomorrow and then I
thought
wait I'm already happy what am I gonna
be more happy tomorrow no I'm already
happy
it's like well then why am I doing this
why am I spending a bunch of money if
I'm already happy so I yanked it so I
didn't buy it and here I am in this
stupid house because it has no obstacles
like it's warm it's quiet
it's not suited to me perfectly but
that's okay like it doesn't get in my
way
and then from there I think how many
other things in our life
are we okay to just not optimize right
depends where you draw the line right
your romantic relationship your job your
family
oh but nobody has the perfect family of
their wishes
our location where you live our diet
like you have to kind of decide
what's worth optimizing that we don't
need to optimize everything it's okay to
have some things be good enough and so
I'm so glad you brought up the Paradox
of Choice by Barry Schwartz I really
[__] internalized that book it's a
great book the ending of that where he
says like okay I've been describing the
problem so what's a recommendation and
he says satisficing there's maximizing
and there's satisficing I had no idea
you're gonna bring this up this is great
yeah yeah maximizers
have been found to feel worse about the
decisions they make they look into every
possible option they try to make the
best possible choice
but studies show that they feel worse
about the choice they make whereas
satisficers
may not make the absolute best possible
choice but they feel much better about
the choices they make so
yeah I think a lot of who I am
is because of satisficing and if I seem
like I make weird decisions in life
for example like not even continuing to
pursue making money it's because I'm
satisficing like I really took that
lesson to heart and have shaped my life
around it just for definition terms
right because people might think
optimizing is trying to eke out the
every last iota of improvement right but
I think what we're really talking about
is wait sorry to interrupt you know like
if you were to hear Paul McCartney go
Hey Jude you'd be like whoa just to hear
him sing two notes yeah to hear you go
optimizing
that's classic it's
it's sick sorry and if that is my legacy
so be it optimizing optimizing I think
what we're talking about is
where to focus your finite energy on
improving versus leaving things as they
are right in a sense right because I
think optimizing when I think of
optimizing optimizing is leading to
Optimal what does that even mean maybe
it's open-ended so it just continues
forever but
it's a helpful word I'm just curious how
you currently think about
where to focus your energy on improving
internal externally
versus leaving things be and this is a
conversation that's near and dear to me
one of my most effective friends
basically has said I'm paraphrasing but
he's like yeah I optimize for like one
or two things and everything else is
good enough like I just yeah I just have
to get it to good enough nice that's it
and he's
incredibly effective in life and he's
also a very happy guy
in general hard to know how much of that
is out of the box versus due to the
decisions and the way he views the world
but seems to contribute yeah so how do
you think about then
where you might maximize versus where
you satisfy or is it because I know it's
not good enough
across the board I find that hard to
believe
hmm
what do I maximize I'm not sure
or maybe maximizes to polarizing a word
no you know what I think it is yeah if
it's really fun okay if you think it's
just actually really fun to like maybe
some people set up their let's just say
they get into bread making and they're
just like I want to set like the best
bread making they're just having fun
with it then great they can maximize you
know people who get really into High
Fidelity audio Yeah and they nerd out
and they know it's stupid
usually yeah and they're just like I
don't care I want this thing with the
gold plated you know cable connector
right and
I think if you have fun optimizing um
then it's worth it if maximizing that is
if the process is fun to you mm-hmm
I think that should be the barometer but
I think that saying enough good enough
is a superpower yeah I really agree with
that you know what it's such a good
lesson to learn is that nobody cares
what you're not good at
okay say more like publicly you're going
to be just known for a few things that
you're good at yeah all those things
that you're not good at nobody cares
that you're not good at them so just let
it go yeah you know
now for the broader public I think
that's really useful but you may have
say a significant other who cares about
some of the things that you're not
particularly good at
yeah
there is that
not that I'm recently single and
thinking about and thinking about this
also or anything we have spent many
hours talking about sex while walking in
the forests of New Zealand
sex and relationships well even before
this podcast
Derek's setting up all these cameras and
all this stuff and then he's like I just
need to take a quick shower and I was
like wait a second yeah we're about to
have sex Derek what's happening I hadn't
had a shower since yesterday I was
feeling greasy it's distracting no it's
funny I wasn't sure if you were going to
say so as you were saying yesterday in
the forest about sex oh no no no no no
no we'll leave that aside for a scotch
outside of recording
the unoptimized life
what effect has that had on you paying
more attention to that
leaving good enough alone
because this is something I would like
to do more of and I've tried to focus
with some success on making Fast
especially reversible or trivial
decisions
right if it can be undone easily
right and I this is also with money
right attention and money it's like I'm
gonna
default to
speed with a lot of things
if it's not that important or if it's
pretty easy to reverse
I think that's been helpful
off the top of my head
I think how important it is to be
done with something so that you can move
on like I don't want
open Loops yeah unresolved decisions
sitting unresolved sitting undecided for
a long time yeah
I feel the weight of those
unfinished projects because I'm trying
to make it perfect you feel the weight
of those and so I think
I've learned the importance of just
getting things done and finishing
and to do that you usually have to say
good enough you know at some point I
love the fact that we say we somebody
releases an album you release a book
because there's a wonderful double
meaning in that word right like all
right I've never even thought about that
released yeah I like that
so I think about that with anything I
post on my site any of my books it's
like all right it's released
it's good enough hmm
all right I'm gonna combine this maybe
another
severicism it's not really ISM but
in terms of how
Professor sivers operates in the world
useful not true
we've been talking a bit about this I
wanted to save a lot of it for this
conversation with the mics
where should we start with this all
right so again I'm addressing the
audience for a second so you know I
figure I'm coming on
the podcast this isn't just one of our
random conversations yeah
this is for the audience there's a
reason we're hitting record it's for
them yep we can talk freely without
hitting record
so I had to think what's the most useful
thing I could share with your audience
that I've learned like in the last seven
years since we last spoke the thing
that's made the biggest difference in my
life a superpower a big huge change so
to me it's been in short skepticism
so if you wonder why I'm so happy why
I'm thriving why I seem to be doing well
to me it's a lot of my happiness comes
from this world view that is radical
doubt it's skepticism and so I'm going
to give this the shorthand of calling it
useful not true but
the visual for it is that moment at the
end of The Matrix movie when Neo
realizes like those aren't bullets this
is just code remember all the bullets
come his way he's like oh wait right
like none of these rules apply to me hmm
that's deep skepticism
it's empowering it's liberating and so
what I'm going to do for a few minutes
including a little stories is to play
Morpheus to help emancipate the
listeners so yes I call this useful not
true
yeah here we go number one so okay I'm
gonna tell you the four bits first and
we'll use that to kind of make sure that
we come back to this so like number one
almost nothing is objectively true
number two beliefs are placebos so you
gotta believe whatever works for you now
number three rules and Norms are
arbitrary games that can be changed I'm
preaching with converted that one and
number four refuse ideology you need to
accept ideas individually
there's the structure so number one so
almost nothing is objectively true
so here's what's true my hand is on the
table but what's not true is it's good
to do everything in moderation here's
what's not true
family is everything here's what's not
true my mother abandoned me here's
what's not true AI is the future
so all of these things
people say them as if they're true or
even when people make any twos like you
know I would be more successful if it
weren't for my family you know or my
location or whatever people say these
things as if they're an indisputably
true fact but to me
the only thing that's true are the
things that both a cat and an alien or
let's say a cat and an octopus would
agree on
if I come up with so many children's
books ideas in this conversation the cat
and the cat the alien and the octopus
because it makes you realize that
everything else is just
mental interpretation right like there
we go this is on the table this is true
yeah but everything else including watch
this one am I flipping you off right now
like am I angry at you right now just
give me the middle finger yeah sorry I'm
holding up my middle finger with the
back of my palm towards him
even if people say things like I hate
you does it mean that they hate you no
it just
they said three words that's all that
actually happened their mouth said these
words everything else is an
interpretation or a projection right so
we have to consider why people are
saying these things if you start to
think why they said something
it helps to dispel it you can say oh you
know what they're probably just
believing whatever supports the emotions
that they want to feel right now right
so if somebody has a belief
that family is everything
maybe that was something they told their
kids because they want their kids to
take care of them when they're older so
they want their kids to believe their
families everything but they have a
self-serving reason to believe that yeah
possibly subconscious right right right
oh so I'm so glad you said this have you
heard about the split brain stories that
people yes okay why did you get up do
you have a glass of water that type of
stuff can I tell you please yeah so
this
is so important to understand
these are crazy
so bananas and we'll start with the
other one since you know that one there
was no no but the audience doesn't come
on no no but we'll do both but during
brain surgery the patient needs to stay
awake in some yeah and so there was a
woman I don't know the details of this
it was on econ Talk podcast during brain
surgery they were poking around in there
and suddenly the woman started laughing
the patient started laughing and they
asked why are you laughing and she said
like oh well it's just it's really funny
the way that that curtain is hanging and
she really thought that the reason she
was laughing is because that's the way
the curtain was hanging but it was
actually because they were poking
stimulating yeah and so the split brain
patients there's some people who's left
and right hemispheres of their brain are
not connected so they've done tests on
these people to
say into their right ear
please get up and open the window
and they'll get up and open the window
and then they'll ask their left ear well
maybe it's their eye
why did you open the window and they'll
say oh it was just a it was a little
cold in here I hope you don't mind and
they really sincerely to the core I
thought that's the reason they opened
the window yeah and there are a couple
more examples of this you know a message
shown to one eye and they did something
then they asked the other eye why did
you do that and every time the people
make up a reason they don't know they're
making it up they give a reason why they
did that and they feel completely
confident that that is the reason why
they did it yeah so to me this is the
most beautiful example like we actually
don't know so talk about deep skepticism
radical doubt
you shouldn't even believe anything you
tell yourself even in your private diary
when you're saying I'm not happy in this
location or I can't do this because of
that or I'm mad at so and so
you need to ask yourself like okay that
might not be true just because I'm
saying it it might not be true so number
two beliefs are placebos
so two people in the same boat one can
say this sucks and another one can say
this is great
but neither one is true
no beliefs are true in fact you know the
little story of Richard Branson before
there was Virgin Airlines you've heard
the tale that like he was at an airport
and a flight to somewhere was canceled
where I was delayed and yeah and
everybody's grumbling ah this sucks and
so he kind of went to the 20 people that
were angry and said hey if I Charter a
plane will you guys split the cost and I
said yeah so everybody else was angry he
looked at the same situation and said
this is great and he you know that was
kind of the launch of Virgin Air no not
launch you know what I mean a
predecessor Genesis story Genesis nice
word
so no beliefs are true when we say I
believe
it's an indicator that what we're about
to say next is not true or not
evidence-based right not true sorry I'm
just I'm just yeah having fun have fun
yeah not evidence-based yeah because we
don't say I believe in potatoes
because speak for yourself
because there's a potato we don't need
to say it because there it is it exists
so I think that whenever we say I
believe such and such it indicates that
whatever we say next is not true it's
kind of like when science is at the end
of a Field's name generally it's not
science not always but very often that's
not the case I can think of a few
exceptions Neuroscience computer science
but very often when science gets
appended to something it's like oh thou
doth protests too much yeah
so since no beliefs are true
I think this is liberating to realize
that you can just choose whatever belief
works for you now that helps you be who
you want to be this is like this is
about personal empowerment it's a little
bit hacking yourself if a certain belief
will help you be who you want to be
right now you don't need to keep
believing it tomorrow you could believe
it for three minutes or three days or
you know the rest of your life
you're going to find what you look for
so if you choose to believe something
you'll find evidence to support your
belief of anything right so the number
three is that rules and Norms are
arbitrary games so this is the one where
I can't help but think of
you know your introduction to the world
in four hour work week giving so many
wonderful examples of how you don't have
to accept the world's Norms yep you know
for sure but it's funny how many times
the rules of the world are stated as if
they're absolutely true like all
applicants must submit their application
through the usual channels and wait to
hear from us or to be an expert in your
field you should have an advanced degree
from a university
but someone made up these rules and most
people follow those rules but they're
not true they're just not absolutely too
so I think that realizing they're not
true gives you an incredible Advantage
because you realize you can make up the
rules so this is that Matrix moment
where the bullets are flying out and he
goes wait a minute this is just code
yeah somebody made this up but I don't
need to run this program
but if you do that people are going to
be upset at you
but somebody's going to get mad at you
and you have to know
that even when they say like you're a
bad person for doing this
you have to know that that's not true
either
good story about that yeah this I think
begs a number of questions living in a
broader Society about morally acceptable
or reprehensible right Behavior right
but that's when I talk about like being
who you want to be
we can't really address people who want
to be Psychopaths or who want to be
damaging yeah because then anytime you
taught anybody how to do anything how to
fly a plane hey don't fight into the
World Trade Center is okay you gotta
drive a car hey don't drive it into a
crowd of people okay you have to just
understand that we're talking about a
tool
not you know your psychosis that might
lead you to a bad person right and table
that for a minute okay so so I have a
funny little story that felt almost too
risque to tell I love I love to
understand let's do it so I don't record
these in front of a crowd it's always at
it
Oslo Norway
[Music]
my band was on tour
and I we were there for three nights
the first two nights
there was this girl in the audience it
was kind of making eyes at me on stage
and so the second night I went to go
talk to her and we hit it off
and we hung out all night long and it
was wonderful and then the but we didn't
have sex
that's funny I was like can I say this
on there we just consummate
all right I'm just gonna say it yeah so
but we kind of regretted it so then it
was the third day and it was the day
that I was leaving and there's this big
kind of Central Park in the middle of
central Oslo and we're in the park
and you know housekeeping came at 10 A.M
like time to check out time to go I'm
like and she was asking them in
Norwegian like please one more hour and
they said no get out she's like
so we go out to this park and she's like
oh God I wish I could be with you I wish
she's like God I just so want to be with
you and I was like damn me too I was
like I wish we could and then I looked
around and this park is surrounded like
you know shh Sheraton Hilton Marriott
and it was 11 o'clock and my fairy was
leaving at four o'clock
oh and there's one detail she was just
in the process of breaking up with her
fiancee
a small detail so this matters because
I said hey what do you think about
getting a hotel for a few hours she was
like ah
well
we could I was like yeah it feels kind
of naughty doesn't it like yeah but
let's do it yeah okay you don't mind
she's like but I can't be seen with you
she said just on the chance that a
friend of mine walks by I can't be seen
going into a hotel with some strange man
I said okay so here's what we'll do I'll
go into the hotel I'll get a room
and then I'll text you the room number
and you come up a few minutes later she
said okay good so I went into the hood
and whatever Hotel it was I'll just say
Sheraton and he's like welcome to the
Sheraton Hotel you know and I said hey
I'm here for one night I'd like a room
and great no problem okay tomorrow
breakfast will be served over here and
such and such and here's your room and
and okay he gives me my key so I go to
the room and I text her the room number
and she comes up five minutes later
so then we have fun for a few hours and
it's great but now it's 2 30 and it's
time for me to go get my Ferry
so this time we reverse it I go down
alone first and I go to the guy at the
front desk
and uh I said hey I've decided to catch
the four o'clock Ferry it's like oh is
everything okay was there any problem I
said no no problem at all everything's
great just decided to catch an earlier
ferry so you know paying in full here it
is he's so he's charging my card it's
already done he's doing the thing but
then he sees her walk bye
and he goes wait a minute I don't like
this one bit so he remembers that he saw
her come in five minutes after me now
she's leaving five minutes after me and
he goes this is not some stupid
establishment this is this is a various
reputable Hotel I do not like this no
you must not do and I don't like this
one bit Yeah he was getting really angry
yeah and I was so happy
because not for the obvious yeah but
like
it was so liberating realizing that like
I've done nothing wrong hmm nobody was
hurt this is fully like consensual he's
you know they were paid for their room
and
even though he's angry he can't get me
in trouble like I haven't broken the law
and I think that we so often
as kids we spend so much of our life the
first half of our life
and of deferring to Authority and
thinking that Authority has power over
us
and at a certain point you realize that
you're you're free you're liberated from
that as long as you don't break the law
even if people tell you you're a bad
person that it's not true they're just
saying that because of their rules or
whatever
so this to me was a major turn point in
my life realizing that I was liberated
from Authority and from judgment
it's a couple things
so the first is
I read a piece recently I think the
author's name is Ava Ava I don't know
our full name Book bear on sub stack and
the headline the title of the piece
something like
on not disappointing myself and it's a
discussion of
disappointing others how disappointing
others but not disappointing yourself is
important I mean that's the kind of
upshot of it
very well written introduced to me by a
friend named Mike thank you Mike so I'd
recommend people take a look at that
because I think it relates
since you made mention of the fiance
though I want to stand in for some of
the audience who will say well wait a
second you said you didn't do anything
wrong but we live in a society we do
follow rules otherwise we are with the
animals
so what is good what is bad is based on
societal Norms I'm sure there are people
listening we're like well wait a second
you had fun for a couple hours with
someone who is still engaged
how would you respond to people who find
that morally repugnant
they had broken up but were still living
together because she just hadn't moved
out yet ah okay all right okay I would I
wouldn't sleep with somebody's wife okay
I got a fiance okay got it but no I know
what you mean that it's in those moments
you have to ask yourself
do I agree with this rule um especially
if you travel the world what's polite in
Japan can be rude in New Zealand and
vice versa
these different ideas of what is the
right and wrong thing to do are
completely arbitrary and they change
with geography and so you get to kind of
pick or choose and you can choose to fit
into the local
Norms or sometimes you choose not to
yeah because you disagree with them
because the same with individuals and
people yeah you're liberated from others
norms
you can choose your own so there's a lot
of this that I agree with I also wonder
how we avoid maybe we don't but it's
sinking into a moral relativism where
everything is okay on some level because
nothing is objectively good or bad
therefore
General mutilation of like 12 year old
girls or whatever it is is totally fine
in that culture because the culture is
different or I'm not going to object to
anything like that yeah because I'm not
the
Arbiter of universal truth therefore
like everything is okay in different
cultures different places different
households because
everything is relative how do you think
about that I defer to Sam Harris
okay did he ever talk about the moral
landscape on your show I don't think
we've discussed it explicitly so if you
wouldn't mind elaborating probably the
best elaboration is to tell people to go
search for Sam Harris moral landscape
the best Ted talk I've ever seen okay
ever that is the one
Sam Harris the moral landscape so
beautifully summarizes this idea of
judging something morally objectively
mm-hmm
based on
individual well-being and so
utilitarianism like greatest good for
the greatest number of people type stuff
yeah he says it better than yeah I don't
want to be I don't want to speak yeah go
find that talk that's cool I'm curious
there's I think attention
sometimes in my mind between
living a
self-authored unorthodox life that does
not conform to Convention for the sake
of conforming to Convention
while also trying to have some type of
consistent moral compass and
that is why sometimes I'm actually very
envious of people who are deeply
religious here are the rules right I
mean you want to talk about Paradox of
choice like how much decision fatigue
does that ever move I'm actually very
envious of that sometimes so how do you
think about I'm not saying you should
think about it I'm just curious like
let's just say outside of breaking the
law you can do anything right there is a
it's just like having 1500 different
types of toothpaste that the supermarket
having to choose one in a sense right
there is a possible decision fatigue
there do you use
for yourself you can Define it yourself
but like good or bad or some type of
moral framework for helping to narrow
the choices that you make available to
yourself
how do you think about that in secular
societies I think about I wonder about
this a lot yeah I recently read
a book I can recommend for anybody
called what everyone should know about
Islam okay and it was really good and it
finally like I finally understand about
the different Sharia laws and it's
really congruent
I think more than anything if I had to
pick one word to give it's it's amazing
how congruent it is um
and what peace that can bring in a
society where even the
the government laws are aligned with the
religious laws which are aligned like
everybody here agrees in this code it's
not a not a gray area
but you asked me the other day about
I said that I'm very influenced by the
greater good doing things that even if
it doesn't serve me
personally or privately if it seems like
it's the right thing to do
I'll do what seems to be the right thing
yeah yeah and this came up very
organically in our conversation I don't
know how do you yes I do remember
because I think I was talking about
how I do not identify as a
philanthropist even though I do a lot of
non-profit work because I actually have
a pretty hobsian view of human nature in
general and think we've probably was
certainly on a planetary level cause
more problems than we've solved and
therefore I I don't fill like philosophy
right like hydrophilic like philic is to
Love Phil is I mean the etymology of
that and then the philanthropy is like
the anthropocene or
anthropology it's human so like to love
humans basically it's philanthropy and I
don't feel like I align with that I'm
actually in the sand like misanthrope a
lot of the time so I said no I don't
think about that and therefore I make
decisions about abrc in the following
way when it relates to
some of the non-profit or can scientific
research that gets funded through the
Sci-Fi Foundation my foundation and that
I think is what prompted you to say I'm
not sure if I think of myself as an
altruist
but I seem to make decisions for the
greater good which I've observed in you
I think that is the rewinding the tape I
think that is sort of the stream of
conversation that led to that coming up
I was asking about how you consider
constraining your choices with maybe a
lens of morality and so you were going
to say well for me personally
I guess I just we have this gut feeling
of what feels right and feels wrong or
sometimes you actually let your head
rule that decision yeah to say
you know what I know that personally I
might
want such and such but I know that
ultimately that's
it's not that important or maybe the
fact that I'm happy anyway
affects a lot of my decisions it's like
I don't need to take some million dollar
thing to make me happy I'm already happy
like I've hit the maximum there is no
such thing as happier I'm already there
so therefore this million dollars should
just go to people who can use it because
that's for the greater good like that's
how my brain honestly Works um
but
this idea of isms
ideologies and subscribing yeah you
tapped into that that thing that we
what did you call it the decision
fatigue yeah it really helps decision
fatigue to say I'm all in on this but I
think that people do it to a fault where
they read a self-help book and go oh
yeah this is it this is the answer I'm
following this now stoicism you know
everybody's suddenly declaring
themselves to be a religion or CrossFit
or veganism right right
the biggest
fault I think to
crypto for that matter you want to talk
about religion yeah it's tribalism in it
yeah enough for everyone I just tried
clear but yeah so something related to
you
happened to me on a plane years ago
that I think is a good example of this
that long long ago I think it was two
thousand eight or nine
I was on a plane from Amsterdam to the
US and I saw a guy reading four hour
work week I said hey great book and he
goes it's trash man and I said really
and he was this guy's full of himself
this book is trash and
and I think about that all the time
because this is like I was a German guy
all right thank you I think yeah and
I've heard a bit of this before yeah so
it's like because he found one thing
he's like the fine Germans actually
outside of the US Germany and Korean
Korea my besties but he found one thing
he didn't like about you yeah and
therefore declared all 400 pages of this
book to be trash right and I think
that's the problem with isms is that if
you're trying to buy into another a
system yeah it's all or nothing and so
once if the leader of a movement says
something you don't like on social media
well now the bubbles popped you know
it's a fly in my dish it's a hair in the
meal it's a poo in the pool
the whole thing is ruined drain the pool
page four to seven in your Dr Seuss
right oh yeah we're back to that I got
the alien and the octopus it's like the
mindset that wants everything to be a
religion yeah you know and I think
that's deeply built into people this
yeah the reductionism I mean it
simplifies reality yeah right simplifies
reality yeah I like that I mean you do
assume cognitive burden to take the
harder path so on that note like back to
my whole like useful not true my radical
what did I call it radical doubt super
skepticism yes I think we should be
skeptical of every ISM I think we should
avoid isms avoid ideology and take ideas
piecemeal yeah which means ideally you
should be open to somebody you don't
like taking their good ideas from people
you don't like and the people you do
like
admitting that some of the things they
say you're not going to adopt that and
when somebody does that to me that shows
a stronger thinker a clearer thinker
somebody who's looking at ideas
individually instead of just saying I'm
all in on this I am a such and such IST
yeah I subscribed to this ISM that to me
seems to jump into a conclusion it's a
punt it's like just deferring to the ism
yeah yeah this is very present for me in
the US and we don't need to go into
politics but with respect to politics
because I am asked
frequently right like are you a democrat
or a republican oh wait I think you're a
Libertarian I'm like I refuse to play
that game yeah if you want to talk to me
about a specific issue
yes let's talk about it and if you can
not just make the case for your argument
but like ideally I mean this is asking a
lot but like Steel Man account argument
just to prove to me you're not
in this to have a shouting match like
okay then let's have a conversation but
as soon as you apply and I think I'm
borrowing from
Paul Graham on this of Y combinator fam
but the more labels you apply to
yourself the stupider you get nice I
think that's true it's just like the
more you calcify
your thinking and or just absolve
yourself of thinking
right which is a luxury yeah it's
deferring which is a luxury if you want
if you want to be an outlier in terms of
the impact you have the happiness you
can
achieve that is a luxury you can't
afford is absolving yourself thinking
or maybe maybe it's a belk who knows
maybe like the people who completely
don't think and the people who think the
most is the happiest to the hell knows I
think a lot of it's probably out of the
box how much of your because there are
I'm sure people listening who are gonna
be like wait a second all right this guy
can't be any happier what a kind of
alien is this guy how much of that do
you think is out of the box just
hmm your code versus a cultivated
do you know Sonia lamburski no okay you
know who she is nope oh
she wrote one of those
books on happiness okay after I read
stumbling on happiness I went oh that
was good that was a good book and I went
to go find other books on the subject so
she wrote a couple books on happiness
she's been studying happiness for
decades Sonia lambowski I think I'll
find it put it in the show notes
so she said in one of her books that her
Studies have shown that most people's
happiness is 50 DNA and out of the
control and the other 50 is in their
control so the best we can do is just
control that 50 you know
sounds like you're stoic
closet oh yeah okay yeah minus the minus
the ism yeah right but did I ever tell
you about that that like
sorry total whatever Forest style change
but like you even talked about stoicism
a bit and I was like ancient crap and
then finally in 2010 I read a guide to
the good life yeah
and I read it
whoa oh my God I thought this was just
me like this is the everything he's
talking about this is the way I've been
thinking since I was a teenager yeah I
don't know why I picked it up maybe I
suspect I found out years later that the
Dale Carnegie book called How to stop
worrying and start living you know I
just as a side note so I've read that
book multiple times I just went into my
Kindle recently to look at my Kindle
library mostly to see like whether it
was 70 or 80 of the download books that
I hadn't read and I came across that
book and I thought you know what this
would be a good time to revisit this
they're very
overlapping
I just read a couple years ago in
Wikipedia or something that that book
was basically spouting stoic values
makes perfect sense and I went great
book by the way folks I had to stop
worrying and start living by Dale
Carnegie it was on my grandmother's
bookshelf and I read it when I was like
16. oh look at that and so here I was
thinking that I would have up until two
years ago I would have said or I did say
all the things that stoicism says I've
believed these things since I was a
teenager I thought I made these things
up I thought this was just me being
weird this was my weird approach to life
but then just two years ago I saw that
Wikipedia entry about he got inceptive
oh wow yeah like wow so but point is
I've been thinking that way since I was
a teenager and it wasn't until the age
of like 40 that I read an actual book on
stoicism whoa this is really like this
is how I think but that being said it's
healthier to watch out for whenever you
find yourself wanting to jump all in
toonism even if it's just a book that
you just read and if you find yourself
blindly kind of saying I you know all of
this this is me this is how I'm going to
live now
unless you have the
let's call it self-awareness or meta
awareness to say okay
I'll try all this stuff on for size this
is like me putting on a suit right right
to see what happens but not like this is
the truth in all caps this is who I am
identity that's totally different see
that's pluralism versus monism like the
monom is to say monism is this
it's mystical the number one is somewhat
like magically mystical you know one
love one world
one answer one way yeah it's very
appealing this idea of one hmm
and it's very
upsetting to think that no no there
there are many answers and they conflict
and you can believe conflicting things
at the same time sorry I accidentally
skipped answering your question about
was it either am I this happy or why am
I this happy or why do I think I'm this
happy yeah so this researcher who wrote
the book after something unhappiness
said 50 50 and then I okay I dragged us
into stosis so that's that so no I I
think I got the lucky roll of the dice
the DNA dice but also there's another
thing I've been doing
since I was a teenager that I found out
has another name too
so for
my whole life I
very often open my diary
and just put everything into there I
write what happened today but also like
the things that I'm thinking
and whenever I come upon a belief that
to me feels like a disempowering belief
something that I also believes yeah my
own something I've said that sounds
disempowering to me like
I hate it here I can't do what I want
here I need to go somewhere else to do
what I want I'll just keep it General
like that yeah then I'll stop and ask
myself like wait a minute is that true
like that sounds like
that sounds like a disempowering belief
let me push back on that I think that
belief might be holding me back so I'm
constantly
doubting everything I write dieting
everything I think doubting everything I
say and you do this in writing yeah I do
this do my fingers just fly in my you
know
so later I found out that this is
similar to cognitive behavioral therapy
so I've been doing this for decades and
now I just found out what it's called so
I just recently read a book on cognitive
behavioral therapy and went oh this
sounds like what I've been doing so also
in the all roads lead to Rome type of
metaphor CBT so I understand it largely
based on many stoic writings Ah that's
right right that makes sense yeah
and it's kind of the conclusion of the
the big archives on the whole like
useful not true super skepticism thing
is you asked me last week
how do you change your beliefs like if
you say this is the belief I'm holding
this is the belief I'd like to be
holding right you said like how would
you recommend somebody do that or how do
you do it yeah how do you translate that
into durable behavioral change right
because it's one thing to intellectually
recognize this is a disempowering belief
it would be much better for me to hold
this other belief
it's one thing to achieve that and quite
a different thing to implement that
latter belief in a way that changes your
behavior
so first you know just writing in my
diary
about I think I need to believe this I
think I need to believe that the place
I'm in right now is a good place to be
not a bad place to be I think that would
be a more empowering belief for me that
I can use where I am to do what I want
not need to escape where I am
for example
so then I need to just Stack Up evidence
of this so it's like once you've decided
on the belief that would be better for
you to hold well you can always find
evidence to support any belief right so
you could just kind of Stack Up evidence
and then I find you know we're social
beings so talking with friends about it
and asking their thoughts on this or
telling them like I'm starting to think
this and then friends if they care about
you and they support you will often give
you other evidence to support the belief
you want to have saying you know that's
a good point you know my friend Tracy
such and such this and she had this
episode yeah I think you're right on
with this new idea of yours so friends
support it and then you start to
internalize it more and maybe it takes a
few days and you take some baby steps to
put it into action or a big giant leap
to put this into action
like you know some crazy things I've
done in my life too I do cut off some
options in my life
as a giant leap we can talk about that
if you want but
small actions or big actions
you can take the action before
necessarily internalizing it totally
gonna fake it before you make it fake it
before you make it yes do it before you
believe it right like act as if I should
sign up for college and you're just like
you're right I should oh my God I just
did like even before you've convinced
yourself you can like sign up that
little form and take that first step to
yeah so I think I've done a lot of
things like that in my life where to
support a new belief I will take an
action first
and then we all have the desire to be
congruent with the actions we've taken
so it's like oh look I'm this kind of
person now this is my belief now so for
folks listening who may want
who would find it helpful to have a
structured way to cross-examine their
own beliefs and maybe take an opposing
stance and then gather evidence
there's something called the work by
Byron Katie oh yeah which is very much
this and I found personally very useful
super super useful
UTS didn't really tease you you weren't
sure whether to open the door or not
giant leaps so with the understanding
that what you do is not necessarily what
you recommend for all people
what are is there an example of a giant
leaf that might make for a story is
there
um
yeah I um I renounced to my U.S
citizenship in 2011. that's a big one as
a way of doing something
to I I deliberately burned the ships
yeah so I have to explain this metaphor
because I found that most people haven't
heard this tale but we've all heard of
burning the bridges so you burn the
bridge when you destroy a friendship a
connection with somebody the bridge
between you and another person
but to burn the ships is a reference to
some I think like a Spanish conquistador
that had headed off with three ships to
South America somewhere and when he
landed there were thousands of Aztecs
waiting to kill them and they only had a
few hundred men of course I'm messing up
the details here but he turned to one of
his men and said we must not Retreat
burn the ships the men need to know that
we cannot go back we must go forward so
I wanted to challenge myself to go
forward and not go back and after 40
years in America I felt like all right I
spent the first 40 years of my life here
I want to spend the next 40 out but what
I found is whenever things got tough I
kept wanting to retreat back to my
comfortable California so I thought I
need to burn the ships
so I did
okay I'm laughing because there's so
many rabbit holes we could go down here
I'm gonna I'm going to use my my
creative license as this podcast to
avoid most of them but
are you glad you did that
for years it was my one of my biggest
mistakes in life made it hard to visit
like family and friends in the US yeah
I highly recommend when everybody asks
me about it some people have found out
about this no handful moral no don't
tell anybody
so when people would ask me about it
my advice was always do not do it in
fact it still is someone just asked me
last week I was like do not do it
Kevin Kelly had this wonderful saying
the best option is the option that gives
you the most options yep I love that and
under that was advice
I think that no you should not renounce
your U.S citizenship because it's
cutting off options
a lot of people seem to want to do it
for tax reasons
you need to look through that thoroughly
I did not do it for tax reasons in fact
my taxes went up after I renounced
because most of my income is still U.S
source so now that all gets taxed at
flat 30 right instead of before it was
like part of a bigger picture so yeah my
taxes went up and it reduced the option
so there was something scary that
happened
just a few months after I renounced my
citizenship my ex
her dad was like on his deathbed and we
needed to quickly get on a plane that
night
but I didn't have visa
and so I went to the U.S embassy to get
a Visa quickly and they rejected me and
I was devastated because they just hand
you a slip saying no you've been denied
for a Visa next you know yeah and the
slip says you may not reapply this
decision is final
and
hey useful not true I challenged that
that rule I was like I think somebody
just made that up I'm gonna go back and
replay anyway so I went back with a
mountain of evidence and luckily they
granted me a Visa amount of evidence for
what I was living in Singapore at the
time and it was actually my good friend
from Bangladesh that said Derek this is
your first time being refused she's like
I've been refused like five times like
here's how to do it you can't just go to
the Embassy and say give me a Visa
please you have to show a mountain of
evidence that your life is in Singapore
that you have tell them about your cat
that you have a job that you have this
that you're on the board at this company
that you're speaking at you know the
National University of Singapore show
them your two-year rental you're not a
Flight Risk right not a Flight Risk so I
went back with a mountain of evidence
and a letter from the doctor from my
ex's Dad saying you know please he only
has a few days to live please allow them
to come back
so I was granted the Visa but it was
scary as hell and so I think that people
are often overconfident thinking like
yeah I'll just renounce my citizenship
and it'll lower my taxes I can go back
anytime I want but not true yeah I
always say like no no once you renounce
you might never be allowed in that
country ever again that is not your
country anymore
so I do not recommend it yeah I would
say in general not to pay too brought a
brush but the U.S
frowns upon people who renounce
citizenship yeah I'm always aware that
I'm in a lot of work to be allowed back
in ever again yeah
okay what
is another example
of a giant leap anything come to mind
and that's a huge one for sure
was it worth it for you so you said I
wouldn't recommend this to most people
and I know we we live looking forward
and not behind we can't change the past
as far as We Know
now
13 years later 12 years later since
doing it it did come in a little handy
in coveted times where
I will skip some family drama details
but there was a big big
pressure on me to move to America
and I was able to just kind of say nope
can't do it
don't have to can't and so finally after
12 years it came in handy for that but
it was a huge thing you know yeah any
other giant leaps let me think or a big
moving God actually
selling my company
came in like an instant Moment of
clarity of like
God life is weird when it's like you can
you can hold multiple
philosophies in your head at the same
time like this is sorry this is the
whole thing I was talking about with
useful not true is these no beliefs are
true so you can
hold them all in your head and just kind
of
look at them like well here's one belief
that says you should stick it out when
the togoing gets tough you need to stay
in there and such and such and yeah
there's another belief that says
the rewards to effort ratio is off that
I'm spending so much effort and getting
so little reward that you should stop
another philosophy says you can just
hold these in your head and
look at them as as paths you could go
down as
philosophies you could follow
and then ultimately you just pick one or
you craft one from a hodgepodge a
piecemeal from the from the other bits
and so in that moment I was feeling
really frustrated with a company I'd
been doing it for 10 years
I was feeling done
like somebody who's been painting a
mural for many years or writing a novel
for many years and just you put the last
brush stroke on you write the last word
and you go there think I'm done that's
how I was feeling but somebody could
have argued like okay go take a vacation
and come back and get back to work
but I played off some different ways of
thinking about it and in that moment
while driving down
Pico Boulevard in LA while on the phone
with a friend I was like that's it dude
I think I'm done I'm just gonna sell the
company and I decided in that moment
it wasn't fully congruent yet it was
just one of many options but like that
night I went and called three companies
that had been asking to buy mine and I
told them yes was there a feeling or a
meal or
something your friends said that
triggered that
he just asked me a bunch of questions
like he challenged the things I was
saying he basically did the cognitive
behavioral therapy with me he was
pushing back on everything I was saying
challenging it so for example I said I'm
sick of having all this responsibility I
don't want to have to do this and have
to do that he said you don't have to do
anything
I said yeah I have to pay my taxes he
said no you don't
yes I do you have to pay your taxes he
said no Derek you need to understand
this you don't have to do anything
who wrote Power of Now Eckhart Eckhart
Tolle yeah I never read the book but
I've heard good things about it I
unfortunately tried to listen to it on a
long drive and don't do that it's
hazardous it's a very soothing voice but
he starts out the story saying that at
one point he just went to go lay on a
park bench and basically just sat there
for a couple years doing nothing and
it's a reminder that you don't have to
do anything that everything is a choice
that even paying your taxes you don't
have to there will be consequences
consequences if you don't but let's
always be clear that you're choosing to
do it you're choosing to pay your taxes
because you'd rather not have the
consequences you're choosing to pay your
employees you're choosing to go into
work none of these things are things you
have to do
and I think he pushed back on that a few
times and ultimately
my value system is such that
I most value personal growth and it felt
to me like I've been doing this thing
for 10 years
the bigger learning growing opportunity
for me right now is to do something else
it wasn't a matter of up or down it was
just different yeah
so let's segue from personal growth
to mentors because many people have had
mentors many people seek mentors any
people Pine after mentors
and if they could only get a hold of
person X
and have a cup of tea or a coffee pick
the brand pick the brain some appealing
have a meal who would not want to have
their brain picked yeah so how would you
suggest people ask mentors for help
here's what I know I have three mentors
so
anytime I think anytime I hit a little
dilemma in my life I write a really good
description of my dilemma before I reach
out to them because I don't want to
waste their time right right my mentors
or VIPs I don't want to waste them any
other time so so first I read a really
good description of the problem and then
I summarize it I summarize the context
the problem I summarize my options and I
summarize my thoughts because I got to
make this succinct I don't want to send
somebody a 20-page long email
so I have to make this as succinct as
possible what is that in practice look
like a half page page yeah half page
like it's like bullet points for
everything instead of paragraphs right
as succinct as it can and then before I
send it to them I try to predict what
this person would say so each of those
three right right what anybody would say
to this but yeah what this Mentor would
say with that Mentor would say I know
the way this guy thinks I've read all
his books I know the way and we've
talked a lot I know what he would say
so then I internalize that
and I address those points that I'm
predicting they would say I'm going to
address those in advance again to not
waste their time when you say dress them
what do you mean by that kind of like
how you asked I said something five
minutes ago and you asked me a question
like can you give me an example of that
or how do you know this so it's like
okay I knew you were going to ask that
so yeah here's my follow-up right so
I'll address those in advance again so
as not to waste their time
and then again one last time I tried to
predict okay well now that I've
addressed you have an answer ready for
whatever they might come back with but I
include it in the initial right summary
of your situation
and then after I've done that whole
process I don't need to bother them
anymore because the answer is now clear
because I've just done the work yeah of
summarizing everything and imagining
what they would say so
the punchline is
the truth is I haven't talked to my
mentors in years
and one of them doesn't even know I
exist
these are my mentors and so this is how
I think it's kind of like Napoleon Hill
talked about the Mastermind or whatever
like he was like you know imagine that
Abraham Lincoln is there what would
Abraham Lincoln say totally so I think
that you're right I also get a lot of
emails from people saying like I need a
mentor will you Mentor me how do I find
a mentor and this is my answer like it's
all in your head it's about the
summarization of your situation thinking
of it from another person's point of
view You can predict what this person
would say if you're a fan of their books
and their podcasts and their talks you
know what they would probably say so do
it yourself
who is if you're willing to share the
person who doesn't know you exist it was
Tyler Cowan ah I just emailed him two
weeks ago to say thank you
especially for your years of service for
his continued inspiration and he sent me
back a tiny little things
Seth Godin is one he knows I exist we
don't talk that often but I very often
think like what would Seth Godin say he
walks the walk he's another example of
someone who walks the walk very much so
yeah
not as common as you would hope no yeah
there's a third it's actually changing I
don't know right now Keith Richards
Bjork but with Chuck E cheese that would
be great you know that
if you have a fictional a fictional
person can be your Mentor yeah you know
like what would well [__] you know what
would Jesus do right yeah like people
still do that like okay I'm not sure
what to do what would Jesus do that's a
perfectly good Mentor
I think a lot of people would agree with
you and for those people who might
wonder I actually do something very
similar okay can you tell yeah
absolutely so I try to spend time with
people I I admire and aspire to be more
like in some capacity right because I do
think you become the people you spend
the most time with so to bring up a name
that we've already brought up I think
actually a lot about Matt Mullinax he's
very calm in almost all circumstances
not all I know what a handful of things
that bother him but
he's very very calm and measured
and good at
perspectival knowledge taking
alternative positions
taking the counter position on his own
thoughts his own opinions his own goals
so I often think when I get dysregulated
or upset about something I'm getting
wound up I'm like what would Matt do in
this what would Matt say to me if not
wearing my shoes what would Matt do
and I've also done that in writing
exercises where I actually just sit down
with my older self oh wow who has
figured it out so if I'm talking to a
version of myself who's 10 years old or
20 years older who has figured this out
what might that older wiser version of
me say
and I just write out the dialogue and by
the end I'm like huh
okay you know doesn't always give you
some magic solution but it is
astonishing how
often that will give you some type of
clarity or maybe relief
that helps you to cling less strongly to
whatever the challenge or problem or
question was that you had in mind it's
really remarkable
so I do something very similar I guess
that's what I'm saying sometimes even
just asking I get emails about once a
week where somebody
asks me a big question by email and then
at the end they say actually you don't
even really have to answer this just
honestly asking you the question helped
me get some clarity thank you yeah
totally yeah like just the act of
opening their email client and starting
with it and going okay I want to ask
Derek servers this thing yeah you know
it's like just even if I intend to reach
out to a mentor about something
I still go through the exercise of
trying to crystallize my thinking so I
don't waste their time
even if it's a really close friend like
I don't if I don't want to be lazy yeah
right and I don't want to ask them
something that could be resolved with
five minutes of Googling yeah right or
five minutes of introspection it's like
whenever I go to anyone I want you all
to say
basically here's the situation
here are some of my assumptions here's
what I've already tried
like I've tried a b c d and e and I'm
not quite
figuring it out and then followed by a
super specific question but asking the
mentors around your imaginary table
and doing that homework I think is is
it's something that I do and I recommend
to everyone and there is some selfish
motive here like I would like to have
fewer than several thousand email right
that come in with like how can I launch
my book please tell me
and I'll admit I actually got
oddly shy two minutes ago when you asked
me who the third one was because
actually it's it's been you in the past
oh yeah and I didn't want to bother you
with things so I'm just like I was
tempted you know I've got your phone
number I could have just texted you and
I'm like no hold on
and I'll just do it personally never
mind I didn't ask you
you know I think about you
I think about you Matt it's funny you
mentioned Seth because Seth would be on
a Shore list for me as well of people
who
really
think and more than think it's question
yeah right the musts the shoulds yeah
the have to's like wait a [__] second
that's nonsense you know I feel like
you're very good at that which is part
of the reason I've read uh your first
book so many times
so
no I'm all shy
should we
I feel like we should do two things okay
I feel like we should get a slight
refill on the scotch and then maybe talk
about games the games we play all right
getting good at games things of this
type so a little bathroom and then
Scotch break what do you think great for
people wondering we just came back from
our bathroom slash break slash Scotch
refill this is
I would say
very similar to a lot of our
conversations yeah like it's not that
different from a lot of our
conversations but I do appreciate how
much thought you give
to deliverables for the audience
makes a big [__] difference honestly
the greater good thing I think about
making an interesting conversation for
you but then there's like how many
people that listen so it's like I try to
yeah you're good at holding both looking
at you but I'm thinking of them no
offense
[Music]
wow we could we could unpack that for a
while
you and your euphemisms all right dark
mirror here we come uh cheers man cheers
oh thanks again Matt I don't know why we
think Matt's there
that's got the Matt's got the fuzzy hat
on otherwise known as the boom mic uh
this is nice all right so
we're all playing games
right and I think it's a matter of
knowing which games you're playing
outside of some Basics you got shelter
you got food and you cover some of the
lower rungs of Maslow's hierarchy of
needs beyond that
we're all playing different games
so knowing which games you're playing
then choosing the game you want to play
these are these are important
topics
why don't I just hand the mic over and
let you talk about how you think about
this kind of thing playing games
maybe not the proper tea up but I'm
gonna go with it no that's what it works
so it's something that might seem
strange about me
that sometimes people say that I seem
weird
because of the choices I make in life
you're pretty weird it's a compliment
but I try to explain that it's just
because
for 10 years or 15 years I was playing a
certain game I was trying to be
successful I wanted to be famous I
wanted to be a successful musician I
wanted to be rich in that way
and I did it
and in My Mind by my own standards I won
the game and
when you win the game say you're playing
Settlers of Catan or Monopoly or poker
whatever with friends
when you win the game
what do you usually do is you you stop
playing you say okay let's go do
something else I won the game
even with say addictive video games so
have you ever played stardew Valley no
oh we don't I probably shouldn't it's
adorably addictive yeah so my ex grew up
on a farm and stardew Valley is one of
those little farming games or you tend
to your crops and then you get animals
and you get money by selling your crops
I think the story behind this game is
also very interesting made by one guy
with a passion for many years I believe
there's a very there's there's a lot of
additional context to that that we don't
have to unpack now but people people can
look into it it's a fascinating
backstory but yeah don't play it because
it's visual heroin yeah I mean it's so
good yeah I mean okay let's say if you
want to play a great game yeah that is
also non-greedy I found it because it
was recommended on a list of like no
[__] games that don't ask you for
more money once you're in yeah you just
pay your nine dollars or something like
that up front and then you've got the
game forever that's cool let's say
actually if you are looking for a new
game it is a great game stardew Valley
is wonderful but it's so wonderful that
my ex
and I got really into it she played it
for something like 400 hours or
something like that the little clock
shows you how long you've played yeah
and at a certain point she had done
everything she'd made every dish planted
every crop caught every fish done every
favor for every village or whatever
she was done but yet there was this
yearning to keep playing because she was
so good at it yeah and the temptation to
keep playing even though the rewards are
done isn't that the definition of
addiction
and so
yes continuing a behavior even though
it's not rewarding you anymore hmm
so to me that's what making money is
it's a game that I've decided to stop
playing because I got enough
but this could apply to anything
somebody who
wanted to be a successful
musician oh there's a great Gautier
Gautier I think that's how they
pronounce it you didn't have to cut me
out you know now you're just somebody
that I used to know that guy one hit
wonder
Gautier from Australia
that was his stage name and he did a
beautiful thing as he has retired that
stage name he's like there did it I had
a massive number one hit I don't want to
keep singing that song for the rest of
my life there is no more Gautier so now
he's just back to his legal name and
he's the drummer and singer in a band
called the basics
and he retired Gotye he stepped away
Jacinda ardern the most recent prime
minister of New Zealand after six years
felt that she had had enough
and she quit instead of going through
the process of running for re-election
she quit kind of midterm and she said
that's enough I'm feeling full I'm
feeling spent
Serena Williams I think you know quit
instead of going longer than she should
have she could after I think 27 years
and like that was enough she hit a point
that was enough
Cameron Diaz I suddenly after watching
There's Something About Mary with my kid
said I wonder whatever happened to her
and I looked up and saw that she was the
fifth highest grossing actress in
America the highest paid Hollywood
actress over 40 and then she'd had
enough and so she just quit to do other
things I should interview her yeah I
love those stories I mean she would
probably not say yes but I mean those
stories are fascinating yeah people are
just like yep goodbye about
the personal challenge of making
yourself do something else
that most of us stay in the game for too
long so I really admire that Jacinda
Arden did that when politicians are
known for trying to hold on to power as
long as they can right until they're
forcibly removed and you know Kicking
and Screaming yeah I really admire that
she did that I was super super
influenced by Felix Dennis's book called
How to get rich
I just have to say it's definitely
not suitable for family listening but
the audiobook is exceptional I think
it's Roy McMillan who's the narrator and
I know that because I looked it up
because I was so impressed by the
narrator oh but just listen anyway I
just want to say how's it not suitable
does it well I mean look you have a very
particular
deep different orientation on these
things but most parents probably don't
want to listen to an audiobook that's
like yeah and then I spent all the money
on coke and Horrors okay that's what I
thought you were thinking yeah that is
one specific thing but that's so
wonderful that he admitted that it's
funny for that reason right because he's
so candid yeah in a way that you would
not normally find
in most books like this Unapologetic on
other things the whole thing is
refreshingly unusual yeah I enjoyed it I
love that book okay so I interrupted
them no it's great and I read that at a
key time it was right about the time
that we met like 2008 I was just selling
CD Baby
and
I was suddenly you know coming into more
money than I could ever spend in a
lifetime and just about that time I read
Felix Dennis's book how to get rich and
in it he had this quilt that I I got
ready for our conversation here he said
if I had my time again knowing what I
know today I would dedicate myself to
making just enough to live comfortably
as quickly as I could by the time I was
35 I would then cash out and retire to
write poetry and plant trees
so I read that at a key fork in the road
moment for me where I just sold CD Baby
I had a ton of money it's like what to
do now and I read this book from this
Filthy Rich old man
being entirely honest and I thought I
should just learn from his experience
yeah and so I took his lesson to heart
and I said all right Felix Dennis said
if he could do it all again he would
just retire and write poetry in plant
trees and haven't planted any trees yet
but it's kind of what I'm doing so if
what I'm doing seems weird is because I
took his advice to heart and I've
kind of quit the game so I think the
here's how we can summarize it is to say
that most people I think
go by the the inner compass that says
I'm really good at this game so I should
keep playing
but I think we should all entertain the
idea we could say I'm really good at
this game so I should stop playing
I'm excited to dig into this because
there's so many facets that I want to
hear your thoughts on so first
I want to pick up on something that I
did not know although I guess looking at
your history makes some strange sense
but wanting to be famous you mentioned
you strike me as someone and I mean this
in a very neutral way and this is also
why I asked you the other day at lunch I
was like what makes you emotional you
strike me as a very thoughtful but in
some ways unemotional person wow not in
a bad way okay but like you're not you
don't have volatile emotions no you
don't have
strong displays of emotion
and that could be a misread I admire
that about you by the way just the
general at least from the outside maybe
it's like the duck on the pond right
calm on the on the top and like kicking
like hell underneath I don't know but
you have a thoughtful almost serene
contentedness
almost all the time that I interact with
you that is my perception that's true
and that's remarkable right and you seem
to have a very very very low need for
external validation that's my perception
yes that's true so that makes it odd or
for me to hear you say I want to be
famous because I'm like what do you get
out of Fame if that's your Constitution
like it's a formerly okay so wait you
know what something interesting came
okay
we won't let that go but check this out
you and I have thought for hundreds or
thousands of hours about the concept of
success yeah what it means to be
successful
I'm 53 now I have spent
whatever almost 40 years or let's say
like you know 35 years thinking about
being successful
just a few weeks ago
in a podcast interview somebody asked me
what's your definition of success and I
said to me it's just achieving what you
set out to do
that's your personal success for that
thing I think it's very individual and
he said nothing to do with what other
people think of you when I went
other people think I was like no what
what and he goes yeah I think for a lot
of people they would Define their
Success Through The Eyes of others I was
like why why would anybody and he said
wait you seriously have never considered
that I was like wow he's barking up the
wrong tree yeah he's got the wrong guy
35 years I had never ever ever for a
single millisecond considered
success as something that would be seen
through someone else's eyes to me
success has always been
hyper personal yeah so how does Fame fit
into that
I think a little bit like the things
that you talked about being competitive
like your personal tendency for sure I
think
as a teenager
I was like I want to get famous not like
as famous as prince prince was like a
musical role model for me he was my
musical incredible musician yeah I
didn't want to be that famous but like
I don't know Brian Eno that's a good you
know Fame role model where it's not like
he'd get hounded walking down the street
and that was driven by a competitive
Drive
I think I used it was more just like
let's see if I can do it okay you know
just with that Spirit of like
I think I can do that I want to try
doing that
and it was also feeling that what I was
doing musically was valid and yeah worth
hearing and so a way for people to hear
it is too someone was asking me recently
because I was describing
how excited I was to see you we haven't
hung out in so long it's been so fun to
12 years God it's crazy because we also
interact virtually I was describing to
someone
that I was excited to see you and they
asked
what made you interesting or
I don't think they said unusual it's
like oh what what's what's he like
what's what's so interesting about him
and I said well
part of what's interesting
is
I don't think I've met anyone
who has the combination outside of you
who has the combination of seemingly no
need for external validation yet
being a good performer hmm right like
you were you were a ringleader in a
circus right
musician you're really good at imitation
voices Etc
you enjoy you seem to enjoy performing
mm-hmm
almost everyone and I do mean almost
everyone and I'm only saying almost
because it seems too absolutist to say
everyone but it might be everyone who I
know who is a really good performer it
could be comedy it could be acting it
could be fill in the blank
had that drive to become excellent doing
that because they
they loved or needed or both actionable
validation I think it's a very uncommon
combination
which is why I was asking you about it
hmm maybe it is because I just had that
live shift where it's like I did it
to a certain point I didn't get as
famous as I thought I could
but I was successful enough like I
bought my house in Woodstock with the
money I made touring you know like by my
own definition I was a pretty successful
musician and then just at the time that
that was getting boring
I accidentally started CD Baby and I
just threw all my attention into serving
the musicians so I think that flips
something in my head where it's like
I no longer need the attention for me I
no longer
I don't need any more attention I don't
need any more validation and now I don't
even need any more money I don't really
don't need anything from anybody but
yeah you're right I still am
socially skilled I know how to get on
stage and talk okay really good at it
thank you you're a combination of
elements that I don't usually see
together it's very rare am I blushing
it could be the scotch
all right so the next question that
comes to mind for me is whether you've
always been a satisficer to hearken back
to the Paradox of choice terminology
from Barry Schwartz or if you've ever
been a Max measure and the reason I ask
is because
framing
games
in the way you have which is once you're
once you're good at a game and you win
it's only natural you'd stop playing
that game is to me
the the journal sequel the spirit the
essence of a satisficer there are people
however who let's just say they want to
be a grand master in chess it's like
this is my game I win that is a win on
the road of additional wins and Mastery
to strive to become the best in the
world or
it's another option which is someone who
has played a game for so long let's just
say it's finances they finally win in
quotation marks
they no longer need to work to meet
their needs
but they have played one game for so
long they don't know what other game to
play
and that Paradox of choice and anxiety
leads them to continue playing the same
game I know so many examples of people
who
have one they've won the Oscar they've
made a gajillion dollars done whatever
they don't have the same love perhaps
they once did for that game but they
continue to play it because
subconsciously or consciously they do
not know what else to do right so I know
this is a hodgepodge of a question but
it leads back to I guess the the first
which is
have you always been a satisficer
oh wow okay the sub questions we are
reversing that yeah this is the whole
okay so the series in fact if you don't
mind I'm gonna I think I might end up
let's do it answering in whatever what
are they so the the third category of
people that don't know what else they
can do that's the category that by my
values
I want to like physically pick them up
and put them into a different scenario I
think it's just objectively you need to
change now you need to Shake It Up in
order to live a full life yeah you need
to see the world from different
perspectives you've been doing the same
thing for too long that to me talk about
like beliefs and you know that's a
belief of mine which means it's not true
but I believe that you should just
because it's not true it doesn't mean it
is invaluable right it's useful it's
useful to believe that you should or I
should put a different one just because
it can't be proven it's true
doesn't mean it isn't valuable I know
we're going to get into some semantic
Rat Hole here so
those people I think absolutely should
somebody needs to kick them out of the
nest shake them out of their habits the
only Celebrity Death that upset me
was Kurt Cobain all the others seemed to
be like okay they've made their
contribution to culture and I appreciate
them but like I wasn't eagerly awaiting
George Harrison's next album you know
but Kurt Cobain [__] it felt like he had
so much more to give
but he was miserable
and some like like that maybe not to
that extreme but let's just use that as
the the farthest and Spectrum on this
kind of person that says they're
miserable doing this thing but they feel
like it's all they can do those people I
just want to like you know physically
restrain them and pick them up and put
them into another environment that to
show them you can do something else it's
a bigger world like or like you're good
enough good in ashram for two years you
can always come back it'll be fine yeah
right just imagine the joy of God
sometimes even a simple manual labor
what is at the end of the movie The Last
Emperor this guy's been through this big
giant Ark and at the very end of the
movie he's just you know picking weeds
in a garden because he used to be the
emperor but the Chinese Revolution would
ever assigned him to just be a gardener
now and he kind of found his piece with
it yeah and we all have different
versions of that we could do you know
like for the most part for the last 12
years I've just been a full-time Dad
here in New Zealand you know I know
there are other impressive things I
could have done but this meant the most
to me impressive is such [__] see
that's external right I mean what really
drove that home for me is I'm a
enthusiastic student of history
and I read for instance
guess it's Genghis khama who really
knows I don't speak whatever Mongolian
or whatever the language would have been
Genghis Khan in the making of the modern
world great book yeah oh yeah really
good especially the first half or so
is really exceptional
but I realized because they mentioned
Alexander in the gray in that book and I
realized
Alexander
it's kind of like Madonna it's got one
name I don't know that dude's last name
do you and like I've pulled audiences
not a single person that's Ever Raised
their hand I'm like okay this is
ostensibly the greatest well certainly
one of the greatest but let's just say
the greatest conqueror of the world has
ever known given the constraints and
Technology at the time can't even name
his full name
so it's just like that impressive I
don't know I've just become less and
less kind of concerned with that okay
wait there were some sub questions in
that last one I can rewind which by the
way is totally developed skill that's
not something this is after doing a lot
of podcasts dude I just noticed from our
walking down the street or walking
through a force and talking
you would pick up on
a few words that I said in passing two
days later you're like let me ask you
some more questions about that I was
like what how the [__] did you remember
that yeah totally trained yeah yeah
which is wild so I was asking you
maximizer versus being satisficer have
you ever been a maximizer yeah so
just like I think you can't preach
minimalism to somebody who hasn't felt
the pain of having too much stuff yep
they need to feel the pain
of having to look after too many things
and having a cluttered house and they go
I need some windows you can't just
preach it to them so I think it's the
same thing with maximizing and
satisficing that I think satisfizing is
a lifestyle for me now or something
that's deeply internalized let's say
because I've felt the pain from trying
to maximize decisions and spending
hundreds of hours
trying to find the best this or
best that or you know make the best
decision I mean God I write in my
journal so much you know so many pages
on something in the end I'm just like I
felt the pain from doing this now I need
to learn how to say good enough and now
that I put that into action it was
because of reading Paradox of choice
I said okay I need to do this he's right
dude's smarter than me I'm gonna do this
so yeah I just internalized it and I did
it and when I catch myself in a moment
see I think like shortly after that I
moved to Portland Oregon shortly after
reading the Paradox of choice moved to
Portland Oregon it's a pretty car
focused City
the city baby office was out in the far
riches and I needed to get a car and I
had just recently read Paradox of choice
and I said I'm going to give myself two
hours to choose a car
maximum and so yeah I in two hours I did
quick research for 30 minutes went out
to some car lots looked at a few options
but this one good enough I loved that
car yeah was it the best possible choice
no who knows but I mean well there we go
for you it was yeah right minimizing
regret yeah two hours and kind of like
the I don't know who the hyper effective
person is you mentioned earlier but like
choosing that they're just a couple
things that you care enough about like I
am glad that Josh waitskin is not a
satisficer I am glad
that he went all the way down the rabbit
hole I'll tell you I don't think you
would mind I believe that it is Josh
actually said that to me where he's like
I basically focus on like one or two
things yeah and then the rest because
he's so intense about those cups good
enough I mean you have to right he's
another one who walks the walk in a big
way right yeah have you met Josh no he's
a role model for you guys would hit it
off he's one of those invisible mentors
not like you know officially but I loved
his book The Art of learning yeah I've
listened to his interviews and I really
admire him and so I have many times
wondered like when I've hit some kind of
dilemma or situation like oh my gosh
wait it's gonna do in this city yeah I
mean no social doesn't read email
I mean there's so many conventions that
he bucks that's really inspiring
yeah I mean that's kind of one of those
you know nobody cares what you're bad at
things it's like I'm sure there's a
bunch of stuff that Josh waitskin is not
good at
and he just you know doesn't matter good
enough
but have I always been like this no I
think I had to feel the pain so what did
you use to maximize
at any point well
I think 10 years ago I over thought the
where to live thing a lot I was feeling
very free after I sold my company it's
like what do you do if you can do
anything but you don't have to do
anything and where do you go
when you don't have to be anywhere and
you can be anywhere it's like too much
Freedom it's a complete Blank Slate with
no restrictions at all I wasn't even in
a relationship
I was just completely Unbound and so I
spent far too long in my diary thinking
of
every possible place on Earth I might
live and why
I could or
I spent hours reading about places that
I still haven't even visited but I
learned all about them I even know what
it takes to move there and you know the
Naturalization law of becoming a citizen
there and the steps to becoming a
resident there and the pros and cons of
living there and I've read books about
it still haven't been there because I
did that for many countries that's
something that was like 10 years ago I
was still maximizing that and now here
we are in New Zealand we're at the
longest I've ever lived somewhere in my
life it's right here I used to always
move around every two years and I've
been right here in Wellington parked up
11 years now that's wild and it's good
enough yeah I mean there's a lot to be
said for it yeah I want to say for
people listening also that you might
think good Lord like this is pretty head
in the clouds one percenter stuff in the
sense like that doesn't apply to me
that's crazy but I would just point out
that
God I got this from a documentary it
wasn't helvetica which is a great
documentary about typefaces and fonts
and so on really cool doc there's
another one about industrial design
and there's an expression in that that
stuck with me to this day I think it was
from a company or one of the founders of
frog design but I could be getting that
wrong
and it was the extremes inform the mean
but not vice versa something along those
lines it's like when they're designing
say garden shears they're not designing
for the average person they're designing
for the edge cases so it's like the old
paraplegic woman who needs to use it
from her wheelchair and then the I'm
making this up but like the 350 pound
bodybuilder who like can't brush his
teeth because his arms are too big okay
if you design for those edge cases at
opposite ends of the spectrum you cover
everyone wow but if you design for the
average person your error rate is going
to be really high okay and so I've
thought about that in so many different
domains so in this case I'm saying
you're providing
from a socioeconomic perspective and
Edge case right like broadly speaking
but there are principles in that
exaggerated state that are easy to see
that are harder to see in some of the
cases that are closer to let's just call
it the middle of the bell curve right so
I would just say that we're exploring
these things and the experience of this
over optimizing and Paradox of choice
and
burnt cycles and something like location
I think everyone listening can find
somewhere right they can find some place
where they're over optimizing in that
way thanks for framing it like that
sometimes I feel guilty
speaking candidly about something that's
actually going on with me if I know that
it doesn't apply to everybody I often
want whatever I do publicly I try to
make it for them yeah it's not so much
my personal expression as it is me
giving back yeah like the world's given
me a lot this is what I do to give back
but it's a nice reminder what you just
the way you just framed it it's kind of
like Felix Dennis writing his
how to get rich book it's like dude is
worth 600 million or something when he
wrote that he didn't have to write that
book and he wrote about his extreme case
yep but for me as a small fry reading it
it was really useful to read what
somebody wanted to talk to yeah but to
read what somebody in an extreme
situation did and how he made his
choices or what he would what he regrets
and what he was doing you know what I've
been meaning to ask you forever I'm
sorry wait yeah I can hold on to that
question maybe it's too late I don't
give a [__] fire away when people ask
the question what would you tell your
younger self
what's the real question there because
I've I unfortunately have taken that
question literally too often and you
asked me seven years ago and I said
women like sex right forgot about that
because to me at that moment that's what
I wanted to tell my younger self right I
felt like culture sold us this story
that that women don't like sex that is
something men want and women reluctantly
give and so for like most of my life I
was trying to be considerate and so I
was like not entirely sexless but mostly
yeah and it wasn't until like my late
40s yeah that it was like oh my God
women like sex yeah nobody told me this
oh my God this changes everything I feel
like had more sex in the last three
years than the rest of my life combined
because this this newfound insight and
so what would I tell my former cell
phone [__] yeah that's what I would tell
my former self but that's just me yeah I
don't think that's the question the
question is what advice would you give
me right you no I'm saying when someone
says what advice would you give your
younger self right but they're really
asking is what advice would you give
someone who is not where you are but who
wants to be where you are that's I think
that is the translation what advice
would you give someone who wants to be
where you are
yeah but it's not where you are like how
to get how do I get where you are I
think that's what people are generally
asking right because they don't give a
[__] what you really what right younger
self would do right they care about what
they would do rightly so
but the answers are actually very
different if I'm being honest right the
answer is that I would give to some
person whose specifics I don't
understand are very different from the
advice I would give to my younger self
right because in my case having a
history of some very extreme depression
and near suicide in college and so on
like my advice would be related to
self-preservation
and recommending perhaps certain tools
like meditation like consistent which I
which I had on some level but I didn't I
think I could have tripled down
on consistent exercise perhaps
supervised psychedelic Therapies
Etc
which don't apply to everybody they just
don't I mean I I think some of those
things might apply to some people but if
someone's really asking like how do I
achieve X
how do I have the life that you have
number one I would say you don't
actually know what life I have
you get the highlight reel and you get
what I share in podcasts but you don't
have the full picture so be careful what
you ask for number two
I don't understand the assumptions
embedded in them wanting X
right because if their assumption is
let's just say and you and I have seen
this in ourselves and our experience and
the experience of many others like once
I have X amount of money
all my problems just disappear right
right like
like the vapor of mist hit by the Rising
Sun like all my problems just vanish and
that is an incorrect assumption but if
somebody's just asking that at a q a
it's up by Southwest or something you
don't have the time you don't have the
right space to unpack all of that so any
answer you give is going to be hopefully
helpful but it could be really
misdirecting in a way it's funny the the
nature that these
questions come to us and is usually
one question asked one answer expected
but if you think of the physical
metaphor just imagine that you are
somewhere on Earth right now
you say you're sitting in somewhere in
Argentina
and a phone call comes in says
how do I get there how do I get to where
you are
simple depends where you are are you in
Brazil are you in France are you in
Finland where are you like but that
would take a back and forth yeah that we
don't have if somebody asks you one
question how do I get where you are
the only honest answer that depends yeah
it's not a sound bite so is the question
you've clapped your hands the question
you wanted to ask what question I think
people are asking when they ask yeah
because I've always wondered it's like
how do I how do I think of that question
I keep getting that question all the
time on podcasts hmm like ah damn it
this question again it's like what I
would tell my younger I think it came up
again just two weeks ago it comes up a
good amount yeah I need a good answer
for that without the snarky saying I
don't understand the question yeah it's
not a bad question it's just so context
specific that it's
not just
sometimes unhelpful but I think
dangerous to give
two broad
a response yeah you know
to use your sort of geographic metaphor
right you just send somebody off in
completely the wrong direction
in the morning oh [__] I'm in Antarctica
sorry about that yeah I thought you were
in France yeah can you go east from
Antarctica how do they do directions
so yeah I mean unless you're at the
South Pole you could give those I
suppose it gets a little tricky but the
good news is there's pretty much nobody
there so you're not gonna be giving too
many directions to people they're gonna
be at some type of base of some type
I've only been once to Antarctica I
actually recorded a podcast in
Antarctica in an outdoor tent with
someone and a field biologist and
photographer
which is super fun you know what
all roads lead to Matt Mullen yeah I owe
him thanks yet again for for getting me
down there it was one of my favorite
episodes here is that a conversation
with Matt and Antarctica oh yeah you
know actually I recorded two I did one
with Matt and I did one with I want to
say her name was Sue flood but I could
be blanking on the name
this amazing photographer wow two
podcasts and answers yeah that was fun
that's what I was asking yeah that was
also if I know I'm mad at all I know
that there's probably some Scotch
involved with that as well
I like how my son
spent time with you in Wellington and
wanted to ask you questions about
Antarctica and instead
he had a more pressing question which is
what is it like to be 16. yeah what do
16 year olds do how do 16 year olds walk
and behave do you want to explain the
contacts we took him to see John Wick
for so what's in general before turns
out that in addition to biosecurity in
New Zealand the people at the movie
theaters are really strict yeah weirdly
and that was off point for New Zealand
New Zealand is a wonderfully casual
culture yeah formalities are very
uncommon here but that was a weird
moment of
strictness where they wouldn't let my 11
year old come in to see John Wick but we
were determined together even though
you've seen and memorized all the John
Wick movies you've seen all the previous
ones he's seen much worse he's read The
Saga comic books oh yeah highly
recommended by the way Saga best graphic
novel anyway so he's seen it all but
yeah so I went in to try to get the
tickets while my son and Tim were out on
the street and he said can you teach me
how to like I'm 16 16 year olds we were
fortunate we had some sort of zoo
animals in the form of three other 16
year olds nearby and so he was trying to
mimic it and I was like okay you're very
smart you're very verbally intelligent
he's a very clever kid and I was like
but the body language and the energy is
not at all matching 16 year olds so you
gotta work on this a little bit he had
pulled the sleeves of his sweaty and his
hoodie up and I was like I'm not sure
that's helping it might be hurting you
look very conspicuous and then he'd
pulled down the sleep is to make his
arms look longer but the proportions are
all wrong so you look kind of like E.T
and I'm like I think you're drawing more
attention than you want to draw but the
whole thing was very cute he means so
much to me that it's
I'm proud of myself that I didn't cry
when I told the story about the
cardboard box in London I almost did
yeah and your answer when I asked you
what makes you emotional was anything
related to Parenting yeah if you guys
have ever seen or go see the song
Papaoutai by the Belgian musician
Stromae it's basically this it was a hit
single in France and Belgium and there's
a great music video for it of this guy
who's basically being a bad dad and when
he and I watched that video together I
always cry hmm
yeah you're kind of tearing up right now
yeah yeah wow yeah it's serious which is
new in my experience of Derek servers
like seeing this why do you think that
is it's
so important the stakes are
well
yeah [__]
well you got a new experience
I'm gonna collect myself for a second
it's the stakes are so high
that it's like if you do this right it
passes on wow holy [__] hmm
we're not in any Rush Zero Rush
hmm it's funny also collecting my
thoughts on how to say this I don't have
to
explain it much nobody's asked directly
it's like if you do this right it passes
on for many generations like a kid
that's raised really well can like pass
that
generosity of spirit you know
oof and then somebody that's raised like
ignored they might pass on that like
scarcity of spirit you know hmm
holy [__] I'm not doing this for the
media this is not like trying to be a
Captured Moment holy [__]
yeah there we go
yeah thank you for answering that this
is new also I'll say for folks
what a gift that you have something that
you
respond this way too yeah
it's kind of the only thing I do you
know it's funny
my ex after we broke up said like wow
I've known you for so many years like
I've never seen you get mad
I've never seen you cry like I've never
even really seen you get upset like you
know I just don't really like I'm a
happy dude
and
yeah like this is the only thing but
it's like it's not a it's not a
obviously like not an upset cry it's
like holy [__] this is such a big deal
yeah
Derek we've covered a lot I'm just
saying I don't I don't feel like we need
to cover anything more nope is there
anything you'd like to say any requests
to the audience anything at all before
we wrap up
yeah I know
you're gonna say this is crazy but still
to this day like my currency the thing
that matters to me more than money the
thing obviously many things do
I still really like meeting people
like I just recently went to India I
went to Chennai and Bangalore for 10
days
and I sat down and talked with 50 people
in 10 days I had one to two hour long
conversations with 50 people and a lot
of these 50 people
are people that I've been emailing with
for years like they just contacted me
out of the blue because they read my
article or they read my book or they
heard a podcast
and they emailed to introduce themselves
and here it is 10 years later now I'm in
Bangalore and we finally meet and it was
so damn rewarding and similar thing it's
like going to Helsinki Finland for the
first time and what do I do I email say
like who do I know in Helsinki and there
were a number of people that had emailed
over the years to introduce themselves
and soon I'm like sitting naked in a
sauna with some dude that emailed me
because you know he read my book this
matters to me more than money so it's
like the reason
I
do a podcast like this it's like I'm
clearly not selling anything yeah don't
have a big ask but I really like it when
people email to introduce themselves
especially if it's not you know coming
with a loaded question like what would
you tell your younger self or you know
what should I be doing with my life but
when people just introduce themselves it
means the world to me it's really cool
to feel
connected with people from around the
world to know that I have friends in in
India or have friends and
Nigeria are friends in
whatever Finland
that's my favorite thing is hearing from
strangers so honestly like my website
which I made myself as a static HTML
website speaking of our earlier tangent
if you go to s-i-v-e.rs
yeah just send an email and introduce
yourself that's my surprising do other
domains point to that
it used to be servers.org yeah you still
have that I assume yeah I'm Gonna Keep
in that forever but that's my minimalism
thing at one point I looked at that I'm
like dot org where is RS
it's Serbia Serbia okay but one of my
favorite tech sites is lobsters
l-o-b-s-t-e dot r s okay I was like Hey
lobsters wait what the hell is Lobster's
about oh it's just a random domain name
they got but it's like it's it's
programmers insisted men's talking Tech
and it's fun it's like Hacker News minus
the business oh I hope I didn't send a
bunch of traffic their way anyway I
looked at the dot org on I used to have
servers.org and I looked at that I was
like I'm not really an organization am I
those four characters aren't really
necessary aren't they I was like I think
I could reduce those and so yeah s-i-v-e
dot r s all right so sivirs are the dot
between the E and the r yeah
perfect
thank you Derek so good to hang out have
some scotch and and make me cry holy
[__] yeah that was my first time in like
three or four years I've never seen you
cry yeah
wow
exclusive
yeah trying to help out my friends you
know get him some more views
they're so good to hang man you too
thanks